um
thanks for being here I'm gonna open up
the subcommittee work on HB 183
um
I would like to start actually if I can
have uh Justin cutting
come up and just share with us uh once
again some of the concerns that the fire
academy has and and how they think that
this bill will will help to resolve
those and we can ask some questions and
kind of dig into the to the meat of it
so thank you for joining us sure good
morning sir uh for the record my name is
Justin cutting I am the director of the
division of fire standards and training
in EMS
one of the struggles that we continually
have is finding enough instructors to
effectively deliver our programs and
it's a significant challenge because EMS
and fire agencies across New Hampshire
are really struggling to recruit and
retain members and this is a two-part
issue if they put in the work and the
effort to recruit these members they
then look to us to provide sometimes the
initial training and at times the
ongoing training we offer a number of
different programs it does require
people to effectively deliver those from
and we seem to have struggled more and
more
the last four or five years to fill
those spots so any efforts that can be
made to help not only the Recruitment
and Retention but for us to be able to
adequately staff those positions is
helpful
either of you guys have any questions
particularly
um
I have some so I'll dig in
how many additional hours I mean if if
we do this it
I mean it's hard to say how much it will
bump up somebody's ability to
participate because we don't know how
much they're participating in other
Arenas that's limiting their hours how
many hours on average per person
uh do you think would allow you to meet
your goals so as opposed to say like
just suspending the rule altogether we
said well they have X number of hours
that they can dedicate to the fire
academy that doesn't go towards other
hours do you have any concept of how
many hours maybe would be useful like
something without exempting the whole
thing I don't have a specific number and
one of the reasons is because what we're
trying to do as a really a customer
service organization is provide the
training that's needed we take in course
requests in addition to our normal
offerings so those courses could vary
over time and they all take a different
level of our number of instructors per
module per program overall and it
depends on the number of each of those
programs that we deliver each year okay
yeah go ahead
welcome welcome to the committee
how many instructors do you have
currently that are
classified as
working full-time at another at a fire
department in the fire service versus
those that you have that are retired
I don't have that number you mean so we
have a total of a 187 instructors about
25 percent of them are group two
retirees currently I don't have the
breakdown on who are actively full-time
working and working for us part-time
absolutely
and you are aware of the cumulative 1600
hours that they can work in the year not
just the 24 hours per week so that can
be adjusted in the classes offered and I
am thank you
anybody else
yeah go ahead this might be unrelated
but I was going to ask the first time we
had the meeting the so do you train
people that are not employed for
volunteer or professional for instance
somebody that just needs a certification
for their job do you know what I'm
trying to get it or those or that's not
handled by you at all that's so for
firefighter training there are
affiliated
personnel which already belonged to a
department and then people that do not
belong to a fire department yet would be
non-affiliated we would train both of
them we give priority seeding to people
who already work for a fire department
that makes sense to train those that
have made that commitment
okay just curious thank you
thank you so much appreciate you coming
in
um did anybody else want to say anything
on 183 who's in the room
and do we have anybody from the
retirement system here
nice to meet you would you mind
thank you sorry my name is Mark
Cavanaugh I'm associate Council and
compliance officer for the retirement
system of pinch hitting for Marty who
came down with covet yesterday
that's unfortunate I hope he's doing
well he's doing all right
um just real quick to start off one of
the major concerns with the piece of
legislation is just how it's going to
affect the uaal
um I think there's less concern if the
retirement system is fully funded but
obviously uh
there is some concern that
pulling full-timers out of this out of
the system replacing them with
part-timers if we expand this will
affect the you know the pay down on the
uaal do you have any insight into how it
might affect that I do not believe that
this would have any effect because there
there are only so many full-time
positions at the Academy or at fire
standards in general and it's our
understanding that they're not intending
to reduce that full-time staff and
replace it with part-time people they're
just looking to allow their part-time
people to work more hours so we we
didn't we didn't even have the actuary
look at that such a small population
even if they did it for a couple of
positions it would be such a de minimis
our other concern would be that as you
cover an exception for one cohort
people get in line and say me too
there'll be schools saying oh retired
teachers it'll be you know whatever
department or or or employer says why
don't I get the exception I have the
same retention needs and the like that
that would be our only long-term concern
that
possibly full-time positions could be
replaced with part-time positions okay
thank you uh anybody have any yeah
representative Gerhard would it be
possible to put a sunset Clause into
this just to abbreviate any of those
concerns I had been thinking something
similar we can discuss it during
yeah for sure
anybody else
thank you very much I appreciate it
you're welcome yes representative Wolf
come on up
representative Dan Wolf from Newbury and
I'm the prime sponsor of this bill
um I think that uh a sunset provision
would be excellent to try it out see if
it solves the problem and you don't have
it forever so uh I strongly recommend
that
recommend that with most legislation I
agree with you thank you I think that
could solve the immediate problem and if
it's not causing something you can renew
it again in five years or you let it
lapse so I would be more than acceptable
to that Amendment
and just from the prime sponsor's
perspective what do you think an
adequate amount of time to let the
program run would be
you got to go at least three and maybe
up to five but I wouldn't go any more
than five yeah so if we went like four
that would give us two terms and then
the next legislation legislative group
could look at it I think that's a very
happy compromise between three and five
thank you thank you thank you
representative appreciate it
oh sorry uh any questions would you take
a question
thank you Mr chairman uh
the representative wolf and taking my
question
um I see here there is an amendment to
this from uh representative Boyd are you
in full agreement with the um presented
amendment that was to put it to the uh
police academy as well include the
police academy I think so they're having
the same situation
but uh you follow up let's go ahead but
it seems to be as it stands right now
the one that is very acute
with no real full time seems to be the
fire service correct that's correct and
it seems like the police do have some
instructors that are compensated
full-time that's correct
what's up
anybody else question for representative
wolf
thank you representative appreciate it
thank you for coming in
thank you
um anybody else wish to speak on 183
foreign
all right well then why don't we go into
kind of executive discussion among the
members here
um
anybody have any uh any immediate gut
we're looking at a couple of different
issues one uh do we extend it from fire
to police as well
um to uh do we completely pull it out
um or do we limit it to a certain number
of hours that are Exempted and then
three potential Sunset Clause to it you
know do we do we put a sunset closet and
when do we do that uh anybody have any
thoughts yeah representative Gerhard I
think three-year Sunset Clause would be
preferable
just shorter if it's good it works it's
not going to have a problem with passing
again
representative true I apologize my my
doctor was not on time
um
well I I missed
any testimony from this morning
um was there any uh
amount of hours listed that people would
be looking for like how many hours does
the fire fighter Academy need
yeah that question was asked because of
the nature of it he wasn't able to give
us a direct answer to it basically if we
remove this
um provision uh for part-time from uh
the rsas uh a person would be able to
spend 29 and a half hours working for
the fire academy in 29 and a half hours
working elsewhere
um as a retired person so a total of 59
hours
um so the question is is do we allow for
that much or do we limit it but we don't
have a specific number of what would be
useful to them to limit it to
yes I have a comment the previous limit
of 1600 hours as opposed to the 13th was
con was considered Enough by a lot of
people so I I was thinking you could put
a limit of 300 hours at the Academy on
top of whatever they worked outside if
that would make sense because that would
allow them
and I'll wait to teach as necessary but
certainly not anywhere near full time so
that's just that's the difference
between the 1664 and the
1352. yeah
yeah representative goalie
thank Mr chair and
my biggest concern is
like was stated by the retirement system
once we open up this box there's going
to be other folks in the next three
years here knocking on the door with the
same argument and
this committee it previously has taken a
strong stance on the number of hours are
the number of hours we're much more
liberal than I think uh and I think we
can get the from the retirement system
than other states surrounding us as the
number of hours we allow our retirees to
work
um some other states I think are far
fewer hours
um
than we have so we're generous already
with the hours we allow our retirees to
work
thank you I might have clarification
from the retirement system on Mike
yes
our hours are higher than most
some states don't allow it at all others
have it around 600 or 900 some have
exceptions for high need jobs like stem
teachers and the like the standards vary
in a lot of States just don't allow you
to work at all after you retire
but we have a very generous in terms of
number of hours right now it's 1352 if
you re if you're retiring after one one
uh 18. and or 19 and um
1664 if you had been retired before that
long as you're still working with the
same employer you had been working with
part-time
um
with respect to people who work for
multiple employers I think
from an administrative point of view
just having a number that's combined
that they can go to you know maybe take
1352 and make it 1664. for those people
however they mix it as opposed to saying
you can work
1352 with one employer plus X number
hours at the Academy maybe someone wants
to work 900 hours at the Academy and 400
hours somewhere else uh that that just
would provide more flexibility be easy
to administer if it was just a set
number of hours and then the person
could decide how to allocate that
between employers
um do you know
uh whether or not other states are
having similar issues with their
restrictive nature as far as routine
there's been a trend to to make
exceptions because of the same retention
issues that we Face here are the states
face the same especially in the teaching
profession so you've seen some movement
to create exceptions
um but it hasn't been a rushed to the
door it's it's not a huge trend okay
thank you yes representative Brown yes
uh
thank you Mr Kavanaugh for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman
I'll give you like an example and
looking at the amendment and this
particular Bill uh like let's say in the
city of Nashua and I did do it but I
made sure I was under the hours but the
shortage of teachers so I did a little
bit of substitute teaching could have
worked more but I always tried to stay
within the letter of the law
but this would is this clearly
significant just to the fire academy and
wouldn't get into another entity such as
the school department or any other
Municipal employment
well well specifically it's designed to
assist the the fire academy with with
the challenges they're facing but if you
were to say
all your hours at the fire academy don't
work that frees up more hours you could
be doing teaching if you if your plan
was well I'd like to do the fire academy
and I do three or four hundred hours and
that limits me in teaching to 900 hours
now I can do you know 1300 hours
teaching because they're not going to
count the fire academy how that kind of
knock-on effect might might occur I'm
not sure but it's a possibility
certainly
yes just to confirm in my mind so what
you're saying this could have a negative
cumulative effect if I did some uh uh
training at the oh I did some teaching
at the fire academy and then also worked
as a substitute teacher uh cumulatively
that sum total could affect this
particular situation correct
I don't know if that'd be negative
it would allow someone to work more than
1352 if we're not counting the fire
academy
you know
that might be positive
person will pick up more days
substituting about the school make more
money for themselves
yes representative gerhardt I'm just a
little bit confused here thank you
chairman are we worried about newcomers
not being able to come into the system
and work is that what the main concern
is that we can have part-timers at
retirees working and then keeping out
new people from coming in to take these
jobs up
I I think that's one of the concerns
um yes that people who are retired would
then be working full-time taking up
full-time positions from people coming
into the system and once again if the
system was fully funded maybe not such a
problem from that perspective because
we're not trying to we're not trying to
fill a deficit that we have and if it
was fully funded then then a person's
retirement would be mostly based off of
their own work that they're putting into
it but right now it's a mixture of the
work that they're putting into it and
additional funds coming in from from the
employers so and representative goalie
might be able to speak a little bit more
to that did you want to say something
no I just wanted to mention
that when I had asked during the public
hearing about full-time staff that they
had and they basically didn't have any
or they retired
relied solely on part-timers that you
know I think one of the solutions is to
get into their budget some full-time
positions that I think would be very
helpful in alleviating this problem yeah
and I know that they feel that way as
well
yes representative O'Brien yeah thank
you Mr chair and just to reiterate on
that
um and for information to uh
representative Gearhead uh
coming from that type of venue and
everything we were always very careful
to uh not get out there into double
dipping think about the public
okay you're working as a police officer
or a firefighter and now you're double
dipping
and I think you understand the
negativity of that what that entails
here even though it may be for a good
reason and what we're doing is the boat
is seems to be sinking and something
needs to radically be done because the
training is of the utmost important it's
got to save somebody's life I understand
that but the thing is they're asking us
to use a non-waterproof Band-Aid on a
leaking boat you know and I agree with
representative gooli the true answer is
for the state to fully fund the academy
but it seems to be a problem in that
department so we're we're doing a
Band-Aid approach to this and I hope
that against some of your point you know
understanding to this
sort of so it's actually cheaper to have
a bunch of part-time people than
full-time position that's basically what
you're saying
basically yeah if you look at the app
because they're already compensated as
far as health benefits and everything
else right there uh let's say if they
work for their uh community so they're
not dragging that into the state level
all right thank you yeah and just real
quickly representative what if you're
going to speak you still have to come
through me so it doesn't evolve into
chaos so you can respond but just ask me
to respond first I'll let you I promise
all right thank you chairman you're
welcome
um any other comments
does anybody have any
gut
response as to something that you would
like to see happen I don't need a motion
right off the bat just
thoughts about
yes no in what way yes representative
can we put the provision for the sunset
clause in okay yeah I mean absolutely um
is there anybody who if we move forward
with a piece of legislation would be
opposed to putting a sunset Clause into
it
thank you Mr chair and I'm not a member
of the subcommittee but um we still
value you thank you I I just like I said
have that concern we started with the
fire academy police academies on board
and then over the next three years while
this is going there's going to be more
people knocking at the door saying you
did them time for us as well we're
struggling help us out and this
committee has taken a strong stance
previously on this issue and I think
we've been generous as a state as you
heard what other states are doing
allowing our retirees to work so I just
caution concern that we're going down
that road so
um once again so this particular part of
the conversation is mostly just about if
we were to do something putting a sunset
clause in or not just from your
perspective because I'd be curious if we
did move forward with it we put a sunset
clause in it it didn't seem to have any
negative impact on the state or how it
operated on the retirement system how it
operated would that alleviate concerns
about extending it potentially to other
branches or are we is it just on
principle
I think it's based on the principle that
we've gone forward with we're allowing
retiree people to retire collect their
full benefit and come back and work
again for the another
entity
and
that could at some point affect
part-time job full-time jobs that are in
the system and that's the caution I put
out there that's reasonable thank you
um so I know that one of the concerns is
if you want to get people with
experience to do the to fulfill these
training positions most of them are
going to be taking a major step down in
pay in order to do it
um and so getting them to agree to
prolong their benefits in order to take
a step back and pay and stay on for
another five six seven years to to teach
sometimes a tough sell so there's that
angle to it too yes representative true
thank you Mr chair
um
we did we have anyone from the fire
academy here today yes
um maybe just a general question to you
um well you can ask him if you'd like
right now they're allowed 13 52 hours
that they have to put all 1352 to the
fire academy they could if they wanted
to
um
I don't know what the extra hours would
be good for
if they've already got 1300 hours they
can put the academy and if I may
just it's it's anecdotal but I was
talking to a fire chief from a volunteer
fire department so he's full-time
um he thought the fire academy was very
difficult
for his people to get training at
anecdotal he thought it was the fire
academy was basically for the for the
training for the full-time fire
departments who had cost constant need
to upgrade and maintain their fire fire
department skills
um but he was saying that it was very
difficult
he'd have to reach out months in advance
to get him or one of his some of his
volunteer lieutenants in for Advanced
Training was very difficult but
I do have a little bit of a concern of
uh of extending the hours
because
if 1300 hours Aren't Enough why would
sixteen hundred dollars be enough
I guess that's that's my my question
would you have anything that you might
be able to add to that from your
perspective
representative thank you for that
question to be clear we train all
firefighters across New Hampshire
whether they're on call volunteer or
full-time about 75 percent of our
firefighter one and two programs which
are the initial training level are
delivered out in the field around the
state and host departments
the struggle that this particular Chief
is facing is not unlike many others
there is a increasing demand for
training balanced with our ability in
terms of budget and Personnel to deliver
that training so that's that's what he's
facing
and and to response or to respond to the
the total number of hours the 1352. if
all of these retirees devoted that
entire amount of time to us that would
be very helpful oftentimes they
work in other part-time employment and I
don't track what they do outside of our
Academy that then
eats into that total accumulation of
hours and doesn't allow them to work for
us so it is a choice they're making
yes representative true
thank you so
in in stopping for the training levels
for the training hours for the fire
academy
would you say it's mostly a small Cadre
of volunteers
that are well you get you have many many
volunteers to choose from
uh
in order to get enough hours in for
training
being volunteer instructors yeah so we
do pay them they're a part-time per diem
employees we have a large pool of them
and when we post a class when we have
any of our programs running we will
advertise the open instructor positions
and on a voluntary basis they can sign
up for those
so we can't assign them to classes
because they are part-time per diem to
representative goalie's Point frankly it
would be a lot easier to manage with a
larger contingent of full-time employees
because we could assign them to specific
programs at specific times
that's just not how it's worked for
generation at least
thank you yes representative
just one quick question
during the covet emergency did the
governor not waive the number of hours
that members could work
so they could work an almost an
unlimited number of hours during the
emergency
I believe he did
that increase your pool or didn't people
work more hours during that time
I don't have any specific doubt on that
but during that period of time the fire
academy like most agencies shut down put
a lot of programs on hold so we didn't
have the demand for instructors
um
is there a generalized
comparison between the wages that are
paid for the academy and maybe other
part-time work that they're doing within
the fire department in other words are
they likely to
prioritize working at a fire department
somewhere else over the academy because
of a pay discrepancy I I don't have any
details on that that is a fair
assumption though okay
thank you again thank you Mr cutting
appreciate it
well
I will need a recommendation at some
point from somebody
as far as how we want to proceed with
this
um yeah I think we're pretty much all
agreed that if we do do something that
there would be a sunset provision in it
so that it could give it an opportunity
to see what would happen and then bring
it to an end you know so it doesn't just
go uninterminably
Um I think that would also potentially
ward off some of the short term of other
people showing up and knocking on the
door because we can say that we're
looking at it and waiting to see what
the results of it are before we you know
make any recommendations for the future
but
um it certainly is going to I think open
up that door
so that's something to take into
consideration
um
the bill as it stands
without further amendment to it
um
of just
removing the hours that are worked at
the fire academy from somebody's
part-time working hours of 29.5 hours
um
are there direct concerns I know
representative tree you mentioned a few
but other than that are there direct
concerns with doing that
with removing those hours out of their
limitation just in general
that's gonna be scared I guess
um
yeah I'm assuming that nobody's prepared
to make a recommendation at this point
on that
representative Davis did you have any
thoughts on that
yeah
down at the moment actually I'm still
new to this whole system here so a lot
of it doesn't make any sense to me why
are there no full-time instructors
um just I don't know what questions to
ask when I don't understand
why the two entities or other entities
aren't treated the same inside the same
system
so the problem that's before us and this
is always the difficult thing with this
sort of conversation
we don't have any control in this room
over whether or not they have full-time
people and and I think many people
probably agree with you on that point
but knowing that they don't have them
and the situation that we're in right
now where at least we're being told that
they don't have enough
um hours to cover the instruction that's
necessary and they're looking for this
to be at least a solution in the interim
to get them from point A to point B
um you know that's sort of the question
that we're looking at and you know we'll
have to make a decision within that
Paradigm right I think that you should
get
I think you should be able to give them
the amount of structures instructors
they need I mean if there are people's
lives on the line a few extra hours here
and there
I mean is it do do the other entities
that you're worried about
um have the same need
to be training representative Bowie
yes because you are also talking about
that would go to part-time police
officers
as well as part-time firefighters
working in District that we have held
firm on 24 hours so even in the towns
working part-time for those departments
we've held firm on
okay I'm just I'm still kind of
following along thanks
um well here's what I'll recommend
because we have just a little bit more
time I think we've got a lot of
information today uh we'll give you guys
a bit of a chance to think about it
further we'll come back next week at 9
00 a.m does that would that work for
everybody come back next week at 9 A.M
and at that point we will actually have
to make a decision on this
I thank you Mr and did we discuss the
amendment
as far as bringing the police academy
into it uh we have not discussed it um
would you like to discuss it
um I think I have misgivings about that
um I don't know enough about the
retirement system
uh to speak intelligently on it but I
would think part-time people working at
the police academy which has full-time
employment
could have a negative effect on the
retirement system itself as far as
part-time people retired not paying into
the system
um
that's it so so I I had misgivings about
the amendment okay uh
a lot of questions about the bill itself
but miss givings about the amendment
thank you
anybody else on that topic
I would say at this particular point in
time I'm hesitant to extend it to the
police academy as well until you know if
we're going to move forward with
something I'd like to see how it works
in a more confined space and I'm sure
that will Garner complaints if we move
in that direction eventually but
um well we can discuss it further next
time but hopefully everybody feels a
little bit better educated on the topic
than they did when they come it came in
give it a week think about it make some
phone calls
um get a little bit more educated we'll
come back next Wednesday and be prepared
to actually
make a motion of some sort so that's
unreasonable
let's um
close up on 183 for right now then we'll
close up exec on that and I will open up
193.
representative Lucas
so in the case this has been recorded
for the record I'm representative Tony
Lucas representing Hillsboro 38 the
towns of Hudson and Litchfield
um
I have an amendment which I sent to the
committee I don't see a copy printed
here and I don't have more than one to
amend part one and
um
you know it's up to the chair how you
want to handle this I can just deal with
that or I can go through all eight
sections again if you like or answer
questions or whatever you want
what would be helpful to the committee
would you like them to go through each
section
I think just yes representative
I don't know how much time we have left
message about 20 minutes maybe 15.
I think
well the representative is testifying
I think I need to know the why why are
we doing this
um I haven't been able to figure out
much of the why
okay I can
at least briefly go through each section
and explain the why in general it's for
the most part it's uh
cleanup of some language this was at the
request to the retirement system this
whole thing
um Carol asked me to to take this on
and I went and met with them and this
bill is the result so
for the part one
um there's already a program where you
can have two teachers share
a job
I guess there was some
there was some concern that the language
wasn't clear there were actually
um you know the original or current
language I guess and there were some
things that got appealed to the
retirement system they made some
decisions on that uh this supposedly
cleans that up and then the amendment to
this section was requested by the
lobbyists from the Nea National
Education Association and it act and
it's uh the retirement system agrees
with it and when this was written the
idea was that I mean what this is is you
can have two teachers that share one job
and the original thought was that some
would be you know they've been on one
day or another day what the original
Bill didn't allow for is if they were
say one did the morning and one did the
afternoon because it was just in days
not hours
and so the amendment
um you know clarifies that and changes
you know which the employer designates a
position as a job share each individual
schedule worked 50 percent of the
regularly scheduled hours days or hours
in that semester for such position and
so
um you know that's what the amendment
allows for
but
um again it's it there was some
misunderstanding I guess and it needed
to be clarified
isn't yeah would you like the
representative from the retirement
system continue as well
yeah
if you want me to speak to this one yeah
Mark Kavanaugh from the retirement
system
um
the clarification here is that
job sharing for teachers is mentioned in
two parts of the statute one refers to
equal
the other doesn't so we wanted to clean
it up so it said equal in both places
and then we wanted to clarify what equal
meant the whole idea of job sharing is
without that provision you'd have two
part-time people didn't work enough
hours to participate so this allows two
people to participate
for one what is essentially one
full-time slot a full-time equivalent
position so we're awarding service
credit to two people even though they're
not working full-time and this is an
accommodation that the legislature made
for a common Arrangement that schools
have with teachers who aren't available
to work full-time but can split a job
between two people
um and so we just wanted to clean it up
and then make it clear what what equal
meant because
um
we thought well 50 50 is equal
someone wanted to say 60 40 that's fine
but if you get to 75 25 should a person
get service credit for only working 25
of the time so you know 50 50 seems to
be the best arrangement we're not
adverse to a 60 40 if uh if it provided
some more flexibility
thank you
so uh can we move on to two part part
two I think we can okay
um so there's some special case uh
things in the uh on the statute around
how the
uh pay for extra special duty is handled
and um
you know that's normally if you have uh
you know utility companies paying for a
police officer to be there when they're
doing work you know on the lines or
something like that it's being paid for
by a third party the thing here is to
clarify that you know if you have let's
say a grant from the federal government
or something else that's paying for a
policeman to do what he would normally
do as part of his job that doesn't count
as extra special Duty
um and that's to uh to clarify that
because that was ambiguous
any any questions on that
go ahead and continue then
just came up in the context of County
Deputy sheriffs doing prison transport
for ice in the federal courts and
the county was mistakenly calling this
special Duty because they were getting
reimbursed by a third party I.E the ice
or the federal court system
but that resulted in people working
special Duty during their normal eight
hour shift instead of doing Deputy they
would say okay you're in prison
transport now for members hired after 1
112 special Duty doesn't count and so if
that person is working two days a week
doing prison they're only working three
days a week as a deputy sheriff and
that's not enough hours to get them into
the system and so we had to clarify that
it's it's not special duty if it's your
normal job just because money the source
of funds came from a third party special
duty is the phone company
paying for a guy to sit behind the truck
well the guys are climbing the poles and
then you building them 50 bucks an hour
or something for that more traditional
concept appreciate that clarification
go ahead Mr okay I'll move on to uh
section three
um and I I may uh I'll let uh just came
out and take care of this but basically
it's dealing with uh potential ambiguity
between the terms newly appointed
positions and newly created positions
and I'll let you deal with the details
yeah when this provision was put in the
intent was to
stop
oh
prevent the
addition of new positions that are fixed
for point a point of our fixed term that
are exempt or have optional membership
the problem is one part it talked about
newly appointed instead of newly created
and created uh confusion as to whether
someone who was newly appointed to a
pre-existing position had the option or
not and we're just clarifying that the
the option applies to any position that
existed at the time the law changed it's
only newly created positions that don't
get the option
okay
you go ahead representative if uh if
people are happy with that we can go on
with section four
um this is a situation where somebody
was in the retirement system they left a
job they withdrew their contributions
and you know they might have rolled it
into a 401k Ira or whatever they did
with it
um and then they come back and work for
a job that's under the retirement system
they're permitted
um to buy back that prior credit but
they have to pay the full Actuarial cost
the issue is it's mentioned in two parts
of the statute and in one place it says
they uh the minimum amount they can buy
back is six months service and the other
place it's a year and so the statutes in
conflict with itself and this just
straightens that out and makes it uh six
months in both places
so any questions from the committee yes
representative true thank you Mr chair
and so and thank you for taking my
question so what would it cost to buy
back six months
they would uh they would pay back what
they were given when they withdrew their
contributions plus additional interest
in the interim
now the reason we have six months is
that uh if a person starts working and
leaves the job within six months if they
take their contributions back we give
back the employer those contributions if
it's more than six months we don't give
them back so if a person comes back and
buys back and they give us their
contributions we don't have the employer
part of it
so that's why we that's why I had six
months the next time thank you you're
welcome
representative Lucas okay and I'll I'll
briefly say on on Section Five that um
this is to clarify
um you know who's responsible if the
employee doesn't enroll in certain uh
Provisions I will let Mr Kavanaugh take
this one
this is what we call employer enrollment
oversight if you fail to enroll someone
when they're first eligible and that's
discovered later that person can file a
petition to ask to pay for the time they
pay their contributions to employer pays
their contributions
but they're not allowed to do that if
the failure to enroll was
through some fault or consent of the
member
and so this last section says creates a
presumption that it's the not the fault
of the member unless there is evidence
that the person person did
consent or the like and so this is we
want to say definite documentary
evidence of the person's election not to
participate so some employers protect
themselves by saying you're in opposite
optional position I want you to sign
this form that you're not joining and
it's your choice
that overcomes a presumption in the
absence of that form it's a presumption
that it was all the employer's fault and
this is just clarifying that that the
election means the election of the
member not to participate
thank you
so if there's no questions
all right can move on to section six
military service credit
so
um first of all it removes some
redundant does a number of things
removed some redundant language you know
that's just completely a copy of
something earlier
and clarify a confusing current
positions regarding what portion of
military service credit is free of cost
and what Porsche requires the member to
buy it back I'll let Mr Kavanaugh deal
with that and also it deletes a section
um that's been preempted by the federal
military code
um it doesn't permit
um you know a certain
retirement things to be conditional and
whether or not they're receiving
military retirement so I'll let you take
the details yes so
um there was some confusion the way the
statue was written before because of the
redundancy whether the three-year limit
on free service
was intended to apply per deployment or
cumulative over your career in the
system
we felt that it was in our long-term
inter long-standing interpretation was
that it was by career
uh recently a gentleman was
inadvertently allowed to purchase more
than three or was given more than three
years for free
because an old purchase from 30 years
ago didn't get make it through a
computer conversion and so we
accidentally paid them for four years
gave him a fourth year because he had in
each of these multiple deployments he
had four different deployments
um he appealed and he won his appeal
before our Board of Trustees so we've
had to reverse and it's now a career
standard and our concern is that
theoretically someone could go out
and do
two years and 11 months stints
repeatedly through the career come back
and work for a few months for someone in
the system go back to the military
military in 30 years from now retire
with a 30-year pension but only actually
worked for an employer for four or five
years was with the military and got all
that other time for free
um so I did a survey uh or I got access
to a survey by a national pension
Association that showed what other
states do you're not required to give
anything for free all you're required is
to allow them to buy back that time and
give them their same job back while
they're out that's the federal military
code that we're subject to as well
um some states
allow you to buy it back only if you're
not only discharged some will give you a
little bit some will give you some free
if you make a Congressional Medal of
Honor or a bronze star you get a year
free but you got to buy it if you don't
and some just say you can buy it but we
don't give any for free uh three years
is is the highest state I could find for
the number of free years given
um so we felt that you know protective
of the system uh that three-year wasn't
appropriate limit and in light of the
recent decision we need we felt that
needed to be codified
thank you any questions
yes Robert no that's what it's for we
got we got three or four minutes off so
um
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question the three years free
that you're talking about
is three years that a person was in the
military
and
is getting
credit for three years
of New Hampshire retirement system
correct
so who's paying for that I'm sorry well
yeah
it comes out of the fund
um which yeah if you could just a little
bit that then gets reflected in employer
rates right just like anything if if it
employer rates or what pay for most
things and plus the employee
contributions so the the employer rates
are the ones that are variable based on
liabilities and so that they
theoretically we'd go up some amount
based on the free service right so the
bottom line is it's all the to all the
property taxpayers Is Where It
ultimately comes from
so uh yeah go ahead representative it's
not um so it's not that
the the employer the town is not being
charged twenty thousand dollars no right
now no it's reflected in the future
rates correct right all right thank you
thank you
and for the purpose of this bill
obviously too we're not instituting that
it already exists more expansively so
right um I'll deal with seven and eight
together they're both a situation where
there was exactly duplicate language in
two places that there was no need for
and that just um you know cleans things
up
right and then if I'm going to nine and
the last one yep
um
in statute there are requirements that
that the retirement system
follows certain standards
um Governor govern uh government
Accounting Standards Board gisb and the
problem is the name has changed and so
it's just necessary to change the name
and statute to reflect the current name
that's all it is
thank you and that's it
and and what I uh what I'm asking uh the
subcommittee recommend is to adopt the
amendment clarifying you know that the
teachers can share
hours rather than only days because our
situations were teach you know one
person may be free in the morning and
then they may have to do child care you
know take care of their kids or
something in the afternoon another one
it could be the other way around and
this permits that to happen and for them
still to be in the retirement system
thank you so much appreciate you coming
in taking your time
um we're about five minutes till 10 when
the regular committee work is going to
start up so uh
I'm not going to discuss this today
we'll come back next Wednesday at 9 00
a.m and um we'll exec both
um both of the subcommittee bills yes
representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chair so do we have to does the
committee full committee have to have a
recommendation for from us at the uh
ready to go uh in other words we we need
to do it now
foreign
as well actually I don't know quite why
oh it's less than ten thousand so yeah
okay
yeah I mean I think we the fire academy
Bill probably will need a little bit of
time next week to deal with that
um
but yes next week I believe is adequate
yep all right I'll close up the
subcommittee meeting and we'll see you
guys in a few minutes
foreign
it's a little bit past time I apologize
for getting a late start here but I
would like to open the public hearing on
hb445 FN relative to operational funds
for the oplc and I would like to welcome
representative ulery
um to
what's that oh
oh all right okay sorry representative
[Laughter]
thank you for joining us
perennial joke
he also does both the same way I do
most of the time
for the record my name is Jordan ulery
representing Hillsboro 13. I had the uh
honor of serving on an oplc uh
Commission
studying the issues regarding the
operation of oplc over this past summer
representing Ways and Means along with
now Senator Lang
uh
one of the problems we found was is that
under the structure of New Hampshire law
you have to expend your Monies
every year
and then spending those monies if you
need extra money you have to take from
here which then
increases the cost that you're going to
assess to the members
who have licenses under the fee
structure of oplc
what was determined from the commission
was that a float was needed if you will
ah
the derogatory term is slush fund but in
fact
it's a fund where you can take monies
from here put it over here and then it
comes back into here again
this
bill that we're permit uh submitting is
changes
the funding from the fees from a lapsing
fund to a non-lapsing fund and then it
specifies the purposes for which those
uh non-lapsing funds are used and only
for those purposes
so it's it's one of the more simple
bills it has to go through this
committee for policy and then it goes to
ways and means and I can see one or two
modifications being made in ways and
means but the general policy is if we
establish a non-lapsing fund
then oplc has for example that they have
an investigation at next and they needs
to take place regarding
ah
I'll pick one because they're up there
and no no aspiration massage parlors for
example are which so I'm sure some
people will immediately complain about
but
um if they need to investigate the
licensees operation they need to hire
either a private investigator or or
another person to go out it takes time
from their budget or operating budget
this will go out to that and come back
in and then it does not have to raise
the fees of every
license holder in order to pay for the
expenditure to investigate this one
particular group over here or one
particular license holder over there
that's that's a just an example it's not
I mean it could be a t it could be a a
doctor or it could be uh any one of the
other licensed agencies a psychiatrist
uh
one of the we did learn that uh
Midwifery is one of the ones that all
everyone complains about for some reason
I have no idea why uh I I worked with
midwives in the field and they're
but you know it is what it is
but that's it's a simple bill
and the idea is to make oplc work better
what we did do and what Edna is now
aware of
we had a variety of different sections
we divided that up this is the first
part
you have a much larger bill
coming forward uh that will need some
greater discussion
with that
representative Schmidt has a question
representative Schmidt does have a
question representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman good to see you
Jordan uh so tell me this is uh you're
bringing this bill at the request of the
about PLC or is this uh I see you've got
a lot of people on the bill with you so
the origin of the bill is your own idea
or is it a request of the agency
a combination of the agency are coming
to the commission and saying we need
some help this is an idea the
commission's sitting down saying yeah it
looks like it's a pretty good idea and
that was a bipartisan commission you
know it was chaired by Senator Carson
but uh uh representing Merchant was on
it and uh uh with me and I don't
remember all the uh right off it is
definitely bipartisan thank you
anyone else
not seeing anyone thank you
representative my house a lot easier
than education was yesterday thank you
thank you so much
next up the chair would like to call
um representative Pearson
foreign thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is representative Mark
Pearson I chair health human no I don't
not anymore
children in family law that's it I do
get to the right room each time though I
I'm going to speak in my role as
chairman of the Department of Health and
Human Services oversight committee it
was brought to my attention last
September a series of articles in the
Boston Globe newspaper about 20
malpractice settlements
on behalf of a surgeon practicing at a
New Hampshire hospital
why it was brought to my attention is
those 20 malpractice settlements and
other malpractice settlements from other
Physicians were reported on the website
of the Massachusetts Board of Medicine
but not on the New Hampshire board it
was silent
so I appointed a subcommittee and we
looked into this uh had some meetings
and concluded that while further study
was needed
we could identify two sticky spots one
may be our rules in New Hampshire on
what should be reported need to change
but secondly we discovered the Board of
Medicine in New Hampshire as a retired
physician serving very much part-time
and as a volunteer
it's unlikely he can give due diligence
given all of that to the complaints that
come his way in other words we need to
have a funded position and why the
non-lapsing part of the money at oplc is
important is absent that we have to wait
probably until the next budget cycle
why should we wait when we really have
identified a problem why should we wait
that long if funds were available to be
designated on an as needed basis that
person could be functioning now that
would
answer the questions that constituents
are asking me and maybe some of you as
to given all of this why is the board
not reporting these things we should be
able to answer that and by funds being
available in a non-lapsing way we could
strike immediately thank you Mr chairman
thank you any questions for the
representative
yes representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
so I understand the idea of the
immediate availability of funds and that
that is that that the uh the fund would
be made whole subsequently uh where
would that money come from
is is that going to fall on the rate
payers in any way to repay the fund for
fronting and the money it's that is
needed I I'll acknowledge that While
others perhaps could speak with greater
specificity as I understand that rather
than having
a surplus of funds in oplc being sent
back to the general fund oplc could
retain some of that it would not be
additional money and no less a
financially cautious person than the
chairman of Finance assured me I don't
have any problem with that
thank you representative Weiler I said
back so it would not be an additional
taxation on us thank you
anyone else
thank you representative
um the chair would like to call
executive director Lindsay Courtney
thank you Mr Vice chair members of the
committee for the record Lindsey
Courtney executive director office of
professional licensure and certification
I appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you today regarding House Bill
445 which seeks to modify oplc's
existing dedicated fund to a non-lapsing
fund just to give you a historical
background regarding oplc's funding
mechanisms
the my understanding is that the boards
prior to oplc's Creation about half of
them at least were General funded they
created
um or they
um they received Revenue through
licensing dollars which went to the
general fund and then they were
appropriated funds when oplc was created
their fund or our fund was established
as a dedicated uh fund and we were
determined to be self-funded at that
time the fund was non-lapsing and then
shortly thereafter I believe it was the
next budget cycle the statute was
modified to make our fund lapsing every
two years or every year that was
problematic for us because our Revenue
stream is is very inconsistent we have
most licenses were new every two years
but it's not
um on a consistent basis so for example
we have extremely high volume renewals
and December and June and so the lapse
every year was a problem so the last
budget cycle we modified the statute to
create a lapse of every two years the
lapse numbers I just wanted to share
with you since oplc's Creation in 2016
was 4.7 million dollars in 2017 5.5
million dollars in 2018 5.5 million
dollars 2019 there wasn't a lapse
2020 there was a lapse of 6.9 that was
for the two years and last year 2021 we
lapsed about four million dollars the
problem with this is that licensee
dollars were completely self-funded
licensee dollars are supposed to be used
for license licensing purposes and not
for any other purpose and if you look at
the the numbers that we've been lapsing
it's been significantly over that 125
percent threshold and personally it's
it's concerning to me that it
essentially we could be taxing
individuals and I think that was the
finding of the committee that was
established last year by Senate Bill 330
and essentially why the recommendation
was made to make our fund a non-lapsing
fund there are some directives in the
bill which we fully support which is
that the remaining funds could only be
used for Capital expenditures or to
reduce licensing fees right now we
haven't been able to modify licensing
fees there's a separate bill going
through that you may see to make clear
that oplc has the authority to establish
fees and rn10 is to level set all the
fees right now we have individuals or
boards that are not paying their their
fair share they're not meeting their
costs and we have other boards that are
completely overpaying and we need we
need to level set that but we also need
to have funding available in order to
support the licensees and with that I'd
be happy to take any questions
thank you very much any questions for
the director yes representative Gerhard
thank you chairman what would you say
supporting the licensees includes is
that oversight of licensees
um it could include oversight of
licensees but for example one of I think
you've seen the Dental Board audit one
of the major issues with the Dental
Board audit that was cited was the fact
that our our licensing portal is
completely deficient
and that costs a lot of money in order
to procure that technology that
licensees can utilize to self-report
changes to self-report continued
education so that they um we aren't
creating barriers to Workforce by
allowing us to license people in an
efficient manner
yes go ahead thank you all follow-up yes
follow up thank you what would
is there any safeguarding place to keep
the licensee okay you want to return
money back to licensees if it's overpaid
but what's to prevent
your department just from creating
programs or more uh data driven whatever
you know I'm trying to get at what's the
key what's to keep you from just
creating more infrastructure and
bureaucracy that's what I'm concerned
about yeah no that's I that that's
legitimate there is obviously our
authority to do what we do is limited by
Statute so if we were to create
additional programs it would have to be
statutorily authorized there's also the
dedicated funds committee that we have
to report to the legislative committee
this is this is a dedicated fund and so
there would be oversight through the
dedicated funds committee
thank you yes representative Lucas
um I don't see anything in the bill but
is there anything else that would limit
how large this fund could grow I mean I
I would expect that if it if it got
larger than needed fees would start to
be reduced but is there anything that
requires that not in this bill I do know
that there was discussion about
potentially limiting to a an amount
certain
um
we would certainly be open to that I do
know it's been my experience that that's
something that the dedicated fund
committee monitors how much money you
have in the dedicated fund and whether
you truly need the dedicated fund or not
thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chair
so is it not the case that the intent of
the the statutory solution or concept is
that the
oplc is supposed to be self-funding but
it's it's not nowhere that I'm aware of
that is supposed to be a cash cow and to
the degree that the funds the excess
funds flow over instead of
being retained so that they can be
returned to the licensees so that they
are not being overcharged for something
that is not necessary to fund their
their Co their coverage and their
Administration
yes that's correct so right now we are
our dollars are being utilized to fund
the general fund which
um is not the purpose of Licensing
dollars and it's concerning if that's a
backdoor tax on licensees and so this is
intended to really remedy that problem
thank you
anyone else
I just have
one so
um do you have any recommendations uh as
far as
limiting the funds like as
representative likos was saying there's
no cap to this so as funds go up
requiring that they be applied to
certain things
um and a certain percentage or you know
certain amount
um so I think the figure that and
somebody can correct me if I'm wrong the
figure that was discussed at the
committee or at the commission was five
million dollars the things that come to
mind are really technology
that costs money in order to procure and
the the problem with you know you don't
want to completely change licensing fees
every time you need to do a procurement
um
I'd have to give some more thought to
that but five million dollars is
certainly reasonable for us um you know
that's about a year and a half's worth
of an existing lapse right now which
would mean that we wouldn't have to
modify licensing fees
um we will modify licensing fees as
noted because some people are paying too
much and others aren't enough but
assuming we didn't
um that would be about a year and a
half's worth of savings if you will
yes representative Lucas thank you um do
you have some general
guess as to the cost of some of these
I.T infrastructure projects as I imagine
you might want to let that build up so
you had enough money to pay for it I'm
wondering how much that might be yeah so
the contract that was just approved by
governor and Council we thankfully were
able to get some arpa funding for that
and that funding is about 3.8 million
dollars I think that should be
sufficient to at least get us migrated
to a new system
but in terms of upgrading additional I.T
costs I'm not sure additionally that
contract is limited to a certain number
of license types and so every time the
legislation or the rules change to
create or modify license types it
requires additional development work
thank you
yes representative Gerard just a quick
question thank you chairman the so some
licensees are more expensive to monitor
where you say they're not paying their
fair share
no what I'm saying is I mean so I think
your question is really how do we
allocate fees
um and what is the cost of a license
um there's a whole discussion about how
we allocate fees but generally the
shared costs we allocate to each
licensee the same so everybody should
pay the same amount and shared costs but
right now some boards when we allocate
those fees are not even meeting their
costs I'll give you an example
cosmetology and barbering
the boards used to have the authority to
set fees and some boards were being
subsidized by others and so there was no
motivation I think uh to change their
fees uh cosmetology for example had only
charged 40 every two years for a
personal license for many years and the
true cost of a license is about 150
every two years so they're at about 40
percent of their costs they also have
additional direct costs because they do
inspections as opposed to other boards
so their costs are actually higher and
so we see other boards like Pharmacy
accountancy
um
paying more
um and the opposite and that's that's
the problem all right thank you
anyone else
thank you for your time
the chair would like to call Stephen
rencourt
good morning Mr chairman committee
members my name is Stephen Rancourt I'm
a licensed electrician in state of New
Hampshire and um the executive director
of the electrical contractors Business
Association the ecba and we're here to
support this bill in concept with a lot
of the concerns that you've already
raised in your questions
um and I I do I have heard that there's
going to be a bill that probably
addresses that more about our concerns
about the dollar amount where it goes
what goes back to the licensing fee um
licensees because it's kind of on the
tail end of the list where you look at
what they're going to spend it on and
again our concern as representative
brought up are we going to just add more
infrastructure or more cost to use up
that money and never do it we would hope
at a minimum this would keep the fees
where they are because they were going
to have to increase them quite a bit
originally so hopefully this will help
if they do that it's important that it's
not it's non-lapsing because most of the
most if not all of the boards in this
oplc are 125 we have been for a long
time so we create another 25 generate
another 25 income for that and it's our
money it's not anything that's taught
the citizens paid for the tax pay is
paid for it's licensing fees that pay
for it and in the past you're supposed
to have that so if you have any issues
one of our inspectors Kyle breaks down
something like that we can replace it
but we've never had that ability it
always got put to the general fund so we
hope that this would this will make a
difference and help with all the issues
that the executive director has as well
as far as some of the infrastructure
the shared cost thing is again probably
discussed in a different Bill how they
come up with that
um
the um we would hope that's something
like we mentioned maybe making sure that
a percentage of what was left went
towards reducing licensing fees to make
sure it didn't get abused you know 30 40
50 or whatever might be left so they're
not spending it all on additional stuff
just because we need it but we also
would like to see the pay grades
increased for our inspectors we're
struggling to get inspectors right now
because the pay grade is not enough for
what's out there in the economy the way
it is we we're short one inspector we
can't fill that position so maybe things
like that can be addressed as well
whether it's in this bill or not or one
coming forward but and I'll take any
questions
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
so one of the issues that this committee
has labored
over for a long time is delays in
getting uh applications of stakeholders
of licensees uh
dealt with processed expeditiously so
that in some cases it can be very
harmful to some businesses if they if
they can't get their people in for in
some cases a month or more
uh is this a phenomenon that your
particular field has suffered under
as far as not getting new people
licensed is that expeditiously
um I think that our particular field in
the electricians have done pretty well
with that we've been pretty
um they've had some technology issues
which I know that the executive director
is trying to fix a part of this and the
funding is is the biggest issue with it
right now it's not working 100 right but
um
for the most part
as we transition it's it's it's getting
better the initial change over to
electronic was tough
follow-up
follow up thank you Mr chairman so uh
you're raising one of the cost aspects
that we're also mindful about to the
degree that the agency is not as
functional as it might be because it
doesn't have adequate funding uh then
the ultimate uh burden falls on a the
licensees and their organizations but
also on the people of New Hampshire who
don't get uh the service they need as
quickly as they as they would like it
and as they deserve because the system
is too sluggish because they don't have
either adequate technology or adequate
processing so uh you I appreciate your
testimony because this is an example and
director Courtney mentioned already that
their
revenues surf up and down and to the
degree that the elapsing aspect takes
money away from them at a time when they
ain't got it
this is not for the benefit of the
people of New Hampshire
thank you and if I may miss the chair
that's that's definitely we're one of
the few that it's been changed I believe
that was on a three-year cycle so and
our license were broken up over those
three years so if you took it in two
year one year might be lower than the
other and it would affect it I mean the
director needs to have it as a whole
picture and not be taking the funds
every year like that to do it so it
would make a huge difference
thank you any other questions yes
representative Gerhard thank you
chairman the as far as the inspectors go
the pay is it indexed to inflation
I do know don't know the exact index I I
heard that they're hoping to increase it
a little bit come next year with some
increases but it's not it's not
compatible with inflation if you take
that job right now that's why we can't
get anybody it doesn't mean what you'd
be making outside thank you
any other questions
thank you so much
representative McGuire did you want to
speak I don't have a pin card for you
okay
anybody else representative ulery
thank you Mr chair to follow up on some
of the discussion that had already taken
place regarding a cap on the funding and
everything else
um this is a first this is a two
committee Bill a second committee bill
will go to Ways and Means normally in
ways it means we talk money
uh ad nauseam
so
we're looking for the policy that this
should be set up at this at this point
not necessarily the details as to
whether or not a cap is necessary I do
agree and I will put in an amendment on
this bill when it goes before weights
and means in about
three weeks four weeks if if this bill
passes out up here uh affirmatively line
passes the floor so about three weeks
after it passes the floor it should get
over to Ways and Means and I'll just
discussed with uh commissioner Courtney
and the 5 million cap seems to be
reasonable I don't disagree with that I
do agree with the cap understand that
the purpose of the bill is to provide
the operating funds rather than having
to renegotiate them over and over and
over and then reapply and say well we
have to raise the individual licensing
fees which I used to be subject to not
with this office but with Department of
Safety
now that's that's a process that doesn't
need to be done
it's a process it's an administrative
process where you can take the funds
handle the situations that come up from
available funds and then if excess funds
are generated
roll those funds either back into the
operation of the of the uh agency or
send them over to the general fund as
you saw from the information that was
provided by uh commissioner Courtney you
have
um three to five million dollars that
will be floating around and in the size
of our budget that's
not all that much money but I would be
happy to uh answer any questions and I
will assure the committee that I will
put in an amendment uh five million
dollars which is what uh the
commissioner has suggested
any further questions
for the representative
thank you representative
would anybody else like to speak on the
bill
not seeing anyone I'll close the public
hearing and without objection we'll move
into a sec
we are now an executive session on HP
representative representative McGuire
moves out to pass second in by
representative Grady uh representative
McGuire would you like to speak to your
motion
is funded it has a dedicated fund but
due to
timing issues
ends up accumulating enough that gets
lapsed to the general fund and so they
are a little handicapped and actually
uh having funds to take care of take
care of their
Improvement needs
the executive director is looking at
license fees and I am proud to say that
in cases where the
statutory Authority for fees
was not there and a rule expired they
actually returned licensing fees to the
individuals because you can't enforce an
expired rule but some of the boards have
been paying too much
for years
and we need and we need to give the
make sure that they have the flexibility
to adjust the fees so that
the licensees are paying their fair
share and not more
and I think that one of the reasons
they're building up a surplus
is that
each individual board was
um
mandated to produce 125 percent
and the bigger boards did
but that was
a number that when when you start adding
up 125 for all the boards you end up
with extra money in in your pocket and
this will help to
smooth out some of those things
thank you I hope I've made sense thank
you representative representative Grady
would you like to speak to your second
yes I would like to thank you
um for those of us who have been on this
committee for a while the discussion of
oplc and their fees is not a new subject
and a commission was put together to
take a look at the agency overall to
make it more efficient and bring parity
to within the organization and this bill
is a policy bill that does that and I
would encourage the committee to support
it thank you
but anyone like to I would like to speak
representative likes yeah I think having
it be a non-lab scene fund makes
complete sense I mean having them end
the uh end of the fiscal year with zero
money and starting over I I can't
understand how they can manage it in
that way
um and you know we'll have complete
confidence in the current director who
knows what the future brings I would
like to see some cap but I'm glad to
leave that to Ways and Means
thank you anyone else
okay
um
so the motion on the floor is ought to
pass and I will have the clerk call the
roll
representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey no
representative true
yes
representative Dolan yes representative
abert yes
representative Gerhard
yes
and the clerk will just
representative groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie
I'm not sure if I was here when the
question was put or if I came in after
representative schuette
yes
representative O'Brien
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick
yes
representative Gould yes and the chair
oh
15 15 yay one nay
well yeah but not eligible
okay the mode being 15 to 1 the motion
passes
is there any objection to consent
they could here 15-1 that's
ah
the yes you're right the financial
impact is
you're right let's leave it on the
regular calendar
and I will write a committee report as
soon as possible
okay and we have a few minutes uh
I'd like to mention that we have a full
day scheduled for tomorrow if the
weather is as bad as some of the
forecasters say and they closed the
state house I'm going to ask to move
those hearings to Friday because they're
all early bills and we really need to
hear them
to just just to warn you if the State
House is closed tomorrow uh we'll be in
on Friday
and what else we have a subcommittee
hearing scheduled for Friday on the list
licensing bills
uh yes I will do what we can okay
your
um it I think that when the notice goes
out the State House is closed last time
when it was closed on Monday they said
these committees are canceled
Friday
so when you schedule this for five
minutes thank you
very much sorry
um so the notice has gone out for the
Friday subcommittee work session so if
you have to move Edna General committee
to Friday is it you're going to arrange
for the subcommittee one to be canceled
notice go out or what what happens
um thank you for bringing that to my
attention I hadn't thought about it when
would you if we have to be here on
Friday for the pension bills when would
you like to have your supplement uh
as soon as we can schedule it when
there's free time one day for
subcommittee
no I'll check and see if
um I don't know can people make
we have anything Monday can people make
Monday
I will confirm that we're able to just
move it up but one day yes
representative well Monday may not work
but we'll we can talk if it happens
I think that the closer we can come to
the scheduled uh time for the bills that
we uh would be hearing tomorrow if the
weather permits uh the the better it is
because a lot of those I have a couple
of important bills with people coming in
and and putting it off till Monday flips
the schedule a lot more than for the
subcommittee so we don't know for sure
that it's going to be but I think your
attempt at dealing for in the unknown is
the prudent so thank you that those
bills are important there's
six seven of them that we really need
and they're all early
yes representative thank you madam chair
if the weather misbehaves tomorrow and
we're in the sliding until Friday do you
anticipate doing any exact sessions on
Friday
the oh my intention on those pension
bills was to exact was to hear all of
them an exec three of the four in the
afternoon because those four bills all
have
all affects similar areas of Statute and
I'd only like to have what carry one
into subcommittee but other than that no
they're
I don't think would exec the others
all right
and don't worry
Man Down
oh thank you that stuff
um we can't we can't load up
yes sir
giving this latest
um
it's a margin of Victory no no but those
those are I mean I've
foreign
good
yeah
oh
foreign
thank you
welcome to Edna
uh I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
341 and representative Broda do you wish
to introduce the bill
you need a pink card
thank you madam chair my name is Jackie
groda I represent Rockingham 24 the
towns of Greenland and rye and I'm here
to introduce House Bill 431 which is a
bill that will leave this committee and
go to finance it passed that establishes
licensure for mustache establishments
before we begin I just want you to note
that this is not for massage
establishments where there is one sole
proprietor we've received some letters
against this bill but those this bill
would not apply to those individuals
you've received from our community
researcher Brad Greenland the background
history on this bill
and it was um it was determined last
year that it should be considered again
for legislation
when it was retained
I'll let you know that there is
amendment an amendment in OLS that would
include Asian Bodywork to this bill
and this bill was submitted because
legitimate massage establishments are
being compromised by investigations that
are that impair the industry's image and
reputation for safety and hygiene
by allowing oplc this registry reports
on inspections excuse me will be allowed
and businesses that are an issue will be
brought to public awareness
um
and that's really all I have to say
about the bill I'd rather not answer any
questions and allow the agency and those
in the industry to address your concerns
thank you representative crota in that
case representative Schmidt
yeah
thank you madam chair
and members of the Edna committee my
colleagues it's uh an important bill
that we bring you today
to deal with a real problem that exists
in the state of New Hampshire
but it's also something that we we it's
important for us to understand what's
really at stake here so the in the
purpose of this licensing bill is
protection of the State of New Hampshire
the people of New Hampshire and the
practitioners of legitimate
therapeutic massage
because uh
we have a situation here that uh it is
it's bad and it's getting worse
and it's really important for us to
understand
that the the towns that are being
impacted are suffering substantially and
we will hear testimony from at least one
of the towns involved and I I actually
discovered that the city of Dover where
I live in where I represent Ward one
it also has one of these illegitimate
massage establishments so it's important
for for us to understand that we are
actually involved in as I say protecting
legitimate Therapeutic Massage
[Music]
and it for those of you who are new let
me just take a moment to to speak to the
aspect of Licensing because we we all
have familiarity with our driver's
license it's it's given to us after
demonstrating that we have the capacity
to drive to operate on a motor vehicle
safely but also an understanding of the
law with regard to using the public ways
um and so this is uh this is not
dissimilar uh to what a therapeutic
massage
practitioners do they have been examined
they have been trained uh they are given
a license uh reflecting their skill and
their ethic
and so
this is a not a additional situation
some of you undoubtedly maybe all of you
have received emails regarding uh the
fact that this is unfair to legitimate
massage therapists but in point of fact
and they say we've done nothing wrong we
shouldn't be penalized
but they've got it backwards it's not
that they are being penalized for for
not doing anything wrong it's that they
are entitled to be licensed because they
are doing something right something
legal something good Senate something
beneficial
uh so one of the aspects of licensure is
as you we all know in in the case of our
driver's licenses if you do something
wrong your license can be suspended or
it can be revoked but one of the
important aspects of licensure is a
license can also be denied
and that is the purpose one of the
important aspects of this bill is that
those who do not provide legitimate
therapeutic massage
practice to the people of New Hampshire
who need it and who want it those people
can be denied a license because they are
not doing uh what the state provides so
I'll be happy to answer any questions
representative Schmidt are there
questions
oh yes representative Bailey
thank you Madam chair
is this bill different in any way than
the one we had last year all right
I think it's slightly different in one
respect than that is it was brought to
our attention uh by uh the police chief
of dairy that uh that the bill has
originally drafted and that you're
referencing that was presented last year
talked about therapeutic massage
establishments
okay but it was pointed out by the
police chief that that the the illegal
practice that that many of the towns are
suffering from
um uh they advertise themselves as Asian
uh Bodywork or Asian whatever uh and
therefore uh that the bill might be
technically
missing The Mark with regard to these
practitioners because it talks about a
therapeutic massage whereas these
illegal operators are talking about
Asian practices or whatever
um and therefore the amendment the
reference that representative groder
referenced is
um also a
deals with Asian body workers they this
committee about 10 or 12 years ago I
think I may be the one of the only ones
who is here uh separated Asian body
works such as shiatsu Reiki
structural integrators and so forth
separated them from the massage
rubric because they said we're not doing
massage
We Don't Belong under massage it's kind
of like asking a plumber to get an
electrician's license in order to do
plumbing
they don't they're not the same thing
they don't belong together so this
committee and this and the legislature
uh did separate out all the Asian
practices uh and put them in their
separate section of the law and separate
governance separate board
and so to the degree that the that the
stat that the bill that we're offering
addresses a particular section of the
statutes and and the lawyers for the
defendants potential he would say
That Ain't Us
so it's it's different in that respect
for sure
now
some some are here and some are not but
my problem last year was and you kind of
led me to that by saying what the police
chief wants the problem here was
it didn't seem to be a licensing measure
but a work a fourth amendment workaround
and you kind of went right to it by
saying what the police chief wants the
police chief pointed out it's not what
he wants he said the bill that we are
offering the unamended bill
looks at therapeutic massage
establishments and it doesn't doesn't
deal with
these Asian body workers does the police
chief have any association with oplc
does he have any associations
I don't know all right never mind thank
you I don't know whether he has any
association with it that's not the issue
the issue is what is the town of dairy
dealing with at the current time
hurt
thank you chairwoman this activity
that's occurring in these massage
parlors is this consensual activity
between two adults
they have no idea
thank you
okay I do have one question
representative Schmidt if you don't mind
asking my asking
on there's one section that it says that
the
uh can you give me three
line seven start section Roman three it
says this section shall not apply to a
sole proprietor or to independent
contractors
which is fine but then it goes on to say
that if that person is providing
services without a prior appointment
they shall obtain an establishment
license
what's that for
well as I understand I'm not uh a
customer of I've never had a massage so
I'm not speaking from a prior experience
but I do know that in many cases
um
massage therapists perform their
their massage
on someone who is unable to come to
their establishment so they the
therapist goes to the home of the
client slash patient uh or sometimes I
think they'll even use a hotel if
they're working out of town and so forth
so they may they may in certain
instances not be operating out of their
usual
facility
and and therefore
as I understand it they would need to
have
an establishment license but that's
that's a hypothesis of my part thank you
I'll ask someone else representative
Gould
thank you madam chair
representative Schmidt I'm trying to
understand
the benefit to
the benefit of the bill and what and
Licensing accomplishing a goal Beyond is
it only for sex trafficking that we're
looking at this bill
labor trafficking as well yeah
trafficking though yes I think
trafficking is is involved but this is
this is to protect the people and uh and
also the practitioners of legitimate
therapeutic massage so
trafficking in the state of New
Hampshire
it's it's that's not its main purpose
its main purposes but is to protect
legitimate
practitioners who uh who in many in some
cases we had testimony a couple of years
ago when we first heard the bill that in
one of the communities the health
officer was treating legitimate massage
therapy as the same as
illicit sexual massage and and tarring
and tainting legitimate ethical
practitioners of therapeutic massage
by lumping them in with uh by illegal
lumping them in with illegal practice
is completely inappropriate
so it's not just for the trafficking
thank you
any other questions for representative
Schmidt
seeing none thank you very much
Mike posack
music oh
sorry
I read them as I call them as I see them
which is not always what it's intended
to be
please introduce yourself good morning
and thanks for having me my name is Mike
posenka I serve as the resident agent in
charge
for Homeland Security investigations uh
here in the state I've served in that
role since uh February of 2014. I have
25 years of law enforcement federal law
enforcement experience
as the
HSI Manchester rack I've led the state's
efforts to investigate human trafficking
uh both sex trafficking and labor
trafficking Statewide uh in 2016 our
multi-disciplinary effort to combat
human trafficking was funded from the by
the U.S justice department uh and
through that funding I oversee two Task
Force officers one from the state police
and currently one from the Stratford
County Sheriff's Office to investigate
human trafficking along with special
agents
assigned to my office Statewide
I'm here to speak today about human
trafficking uh what it is our general
approach to invest to investigating this
crime and the threat that illicit
massage businesses
um opposed to human trafficking
human trafficking is the use of force
fraud or coercion to compel an
individual into some kind of Labor
whether that's commercial sex acts or
any other kind of Labor we've seen it in
the state in the agricultural uh
industry as long as as well as the
construction industry
uh and and we investigate human
trafficking in whatever form it it
presents itself to us whether that's sex
trafficking or labor trafficking
uh sex trafficking is presented itself
where familial or intimate or societal
relationships are present
we take a victim-centered approach to
investigating human trafficking that
means our ultimate goal is to hold
accountable the individuals who are
profiting the most from this sort of
activity uh we we craft our
investigative approach to avoid holding
potential victims of human trafficking
accountable for relatively minor
offenses uh that have been committed
incidental to having been trafficked
human trafficking criminal human
trafficking cases are very difficult to
to make because we rely on testimony uh
and cooperation from the victims and in
order to gain that sort of testimony we
have to overcome the dynamic that's
going on between the trafficker and and
the victim and that the the trafficker
in these K the the victim in these cases
are reliant on these traffickers to meet
their needs whether it's a drug
addiction uh need or a housing need or a
food need uh
in every human trafficking case that we
have investigated the victim is
reluctant to cooperate with law
enforcement as a result of these loyalty
uh these loyalties and out of fear
um though that type of dynamic is is
present in our illicit massage business
uh investigations because we have
victims uh who are either foreign
Nationals or who are newly naturalized
U.S citizens who have uh very limited
English ability
the the jobs that the the ownership in
these uh establishments are of that same
uh ethnicity
uh the employees are relying on the
business owners for items such as living
quarters transportation and even food in
in the illicit massage business cases
um
we've made criminal cases against
illicit massage business owners uh in
the past but they're very difficult to
to obtain and we've done so without the
cooperation of the potential victims in
these cases because we've been unable to
pierce that trust or that societal
obligation that the victim has towards
the the trafficker so I want to right
now I want to dispel some a myth about
human trafficking and and it's it's a
myth that we see in the in the media we
see it in in Hollywood if you've seen
the movie Taken you have a very
clear-cut example of human trafficking
that victim was that portrayed victim
was was drugged and sold into the sex
trade that's not what we see in reality
on the uh on the streets what we're
seeing is uh victims who are doing what
they have to do in order to survive in
order to feed that drug addiction or or
in order to make a living and and and
stay in the U.S so representative
Gerhart to to address your question
earlier is this is this occurring
between two
um consenting adults
my initial answer would say I don't know
because there is that veil of uh of of
secrecy that's going on in these in
these cases that I'm unable to pierce
very often so if there's exploitation
going on I'm not getting the cooperation
from the the victims in these cases
um in order to establish that
um
and to and and also my secondary answer
would be we have had juveniles go into
illicit massage businesses and
um and and be assaulted frankly
um sexually in in these in these
establishments so we we've coming from
from both both sides there we've we've
seen juveniles and I can't say that
these are consulting or non-consulting
consenting what I say Consulting
consenting I'm sorry consenting yeah
yeah
um
so one way that we address uh the human
trafficking threat posed by these
businesses is by Our Own federal
um regulatory Authority I have one
Auditor in the state and he's
responsible for uh identifying these
illicit businesses and he
um serves the appropriate paperwork and
he audits them for our audit Authority
has to do with
um ensuring that business owners comply
with
um uh with with their responsibility
their their um lawful that that their
employees are lawfully present in the
U.S and have employment authorization
it's a a form I-9 audit uh which we all
have filled out for our employer
um
the regulatory Authority in this bill
will help uh this regulatory approach to
combating human trafficking in a
victim-centered manner uh it will assist
us in our efforts to hold accountable
the potential trafficker and the ones
who are capitalizing from this activity
and not the potential victim
I appreciate your time I'm certainly
available to answer questions thank you
uh this bill will be going to
subcommittee so we may ask you to
support it if possible
okay representative Dolan thank you
madam chair uh and thank you for the the
work that you do my question is given
the current porosity of the of our
border situation are you seeing an
uptick
downtick or about the same level of uh
of problem that you're describing
here in the state I'm seeing about about
the same I don't think that the the
threat posed by these illicit massage
businesses are a reflection of what's
going on at the border uh in in fact the
uh the employees at these in these
businesses are generally lawfully
present in the U.S they um they
they have a Asylum status permanent
residence status or even
um naturalized U.S citizen status thank
you thank you representative Fitzgerald
oh
Fitzpatrick excuse me thank you madam
chair
uh
would it be accurate to uh Khan
conclude that the victims have their own
form of uh
Stockholm Syndrome
um
yeah that would be a syndrome where they
are under the spell of a of a trafficker
and and certain
psychological issues are going on and
they feel like they owe a duty to their
uh their employer I I would is that what
you mean by stock follow-up yeah uh
obviously they're they're being fed
housed clothed and and just like a
kidnapping victim over a period of weeks
or months they form a
re
re excuse me I stutter fruits who don't
know a
relationship with their uh abductor in
in this case a kidnapping victim but but
the way that I'm reading what you're
saying they form their own type of uh
stockholming Stockholm syndrome with
their employer in this case
I would generally agree with that I'm
not a psychologist and I don't think I'm
in the in a position to make that kind
of diagnosis diagnosis but okay I would
generally agree representative Gould
thank you madam chair
I'm concerned that this bill that's
really about a policy for
um licensing
massage therapists are is turning into a
sex trafficking but there's a comment
you made or an impression I'm getting
from your testimony that I couldn't let
pass
having worked with victims of
whatever I'm a social worker so uh is it
your testimony to the committee that
all of the sex trafficking issues are
about immigrants and that there are no
white rich powerful men in New Hampshire
who are involved in taking advantage of
women and illicit sex trade is that your
testimony no that's absolutely not my
testimony thank you yeah
okay thank you representative of a bear
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here today to talk about this
difficult subject my question is that
how would you categorize
the
businesses that you're seeing this sex
trafficking in versus the multiple
good
massage therapy businesses that are out
there in other words how how would you
if you were to make a left side of the
column and the right side of the column
how do you identify these from a
distance or from your trained eyes at
what you're looking at I spoke recently
to a town in New Hampshire that was
easily able to identify them I want to
know how do you identify and categorize
the left column versus the right column
please thank you yes ma'am that's a
great question and I um I don't want to
get into too many particulars about our
investigative approach to to
establishing this but we take a um a few
different a few different steps one
would be a report from the general
public or from the local police
department that there is uh commercial
sex activity occurring in these
establishments we would we would take
certain steps such as
um
uh looking at
[Music]
um
publicly available information to
um to conclude that there's a a high or
a high probability that prostitution is
going on in these in these
establishments
follow-up Madam um
just a brief one it's I believe he's
stated he doesn't want to give you too
much information
thank you
my my question then would be is there
any way in your experience that from an
ordinance standpoint with as you said a
report from the public a report from the
police department things that are
publicly available that could could be
constructed at an ordinance level rather
than a state law
I'm sorry I don't understand the
question
may I clarify Madison
my my question is
is there in your opinion is there any
way to
is there any other way to fix or fix
these problems without overlaying an
entire RSA across all massage therapists
by use of ordinance does that clear it
up yeah uh and no not not that I can
I mean I'm happy to just to talk about
uh Alternatives but I I
I can't think of one of my own
okay representative Gerhart thank you
madam chair
so as far as identifying these
businesses we received some online
testimony from various people one was a
owner of a massage parlor and I just
read briefly from her email as an LMT I
cannot tell I cannot Oh weird I cannot
being to tell you how many phone calls I
get in a week asking if I offer more
than just massage I am buntly X if I
offer Happy Endings I have no recourse
with these calls there's nothing
misunderstood in the attentions of the
caller I advise a call that I'm book
style and they can call the following
phone number then I give them the police
non-emergency line as a therapist I need
recourse to have action taken against
these callers when I called the police
they tell me that no offense has
occurred and that and that no I'm just
fixing it there's nothing that can be
done I'm being solicited for sexual
favors how is this not an offense now
I'm not here to say that is or isn't an
offense I don't know and that's not my
thing but if people can actively call
these places and ask for these Services
is there really much investigation be
done besides just sitting with a Rolodex
and calling these businesses do we need
this bill that's what I'm trying to get
it seems like these these businesses
that are soliciting this are doing it
openly because she's receiving calls so
this is not something in the dark thank
you
well she's receiving cold calls she's
not receiving any calls from someone
that
any kind of response to any kind of
advertisement that she's
put out that would somehow somehow
suggest that
her business is
engaging in this in this sort of
activity
um
so
yeah I'm having a hard time
understanding
what do you mean by the word
investigation a regulatory investigation
or a criminal investigation because if
we're talking about a criminal
investigation which is what my office
predominantly does we do some some
audits but
um I have one auditor I have nine
criminal investigators
um
on on the criminal side just that sort
of
um solicitation or and and this and the
the advertisements aren't explicit
they don't specifically say we offer sex
acts they they they're just
um they're known in the community
um to to provide sex acts the word the
word gets out so that but that in itself
without an act we wouldn't be able to to
use any kind of criminal statute
if I may representative Gerhart I think
he's concerned that you don't need a
whole lot of Investigation if you can
just call them up and say you know do
you offer sex and they say oh sure what
when do you want an appointment
I mean that that would be
you know and and then what
well then you've identified your uh your
suspects right off the bat yeah but we
don't have any any recourse
way beyond our scope to be honest with
you I think the
uh
representative shewitt
thank you madam chair
um thank you very much for testifying
today
we heard on the bills last year and and
previous bills that part of the
difficulty with investigating these
illicit businesses was and right now the
fact that it's controlled by local
ordinances and we heard that one of
these businesses would operate in one
town and if they were being investigated
they would just shut down and move to a
different jurisdiction
is it your understanding that this bill
would help overcome that difficulty and
still be able to
investigate these businesses wherever
they go to
no I don't I don't believe that this
bill would prevent them from picking up
shop and moving moving somewhere else uh
that's that's something that we do see
uh and we've seen it as a result of our
regulatory action uh as well I I don't I
don't think that would stop
thank you other
yes representative Gould
do you think this bill will
curtail illicit sexual trade in New
Hampshire
uh I do yeah I I think it'll be another
tool for us to put the business owners
on record that they are being
scrutinized by the government and it
would it would help to
um to to build a dossier to justify
further criminal investigation thank you
and thank you madam chair
other questions
all right thank you very much for your
testimony okay thank you
Beverly dando
from Salem
Dairy oh
okay yes
again I'm having trouble with the
handwriting
turn your mic on
all right there you go thank you good
morning my name is Beverly Donovan I'm
the economic development director for
the town of Derry
um I don't want to rehash what's already
been said so I thought maybe it would be
helpful to take you through our process
to understand even how we can
differentiate between the legitimate
um
organizations that provide massage
versus some of the illegitimate
um or illicit massage parlors
in the town of Derry part of my job is
to get to know all of the businesses so
when somebody comes in to start a new
business I usually meet with them we
talk about what they'll be doing where
they're going to be going and so on and
I help them through what we call our
change of use paperwork which I think
pretty much every town has this system
so that all of the Departments are aware
of who is in business in town emergency
contacts and so on
um in that change of use over the past
five years that I've been working for
dairy we've changed that so that we now
um and this was partly because of covid
we now ask for more detail about where
people live and can be reached in the
event that shutdowns happen or so on and
we also ask for our description of their
business and this is across the board
for every business
um what we've been finding
um is there's just one segment of the
population offering massage and there
are many many legit therapeutic massage
businesses but there is a segment in
particular and this is how they are
called out is Asian Body Works and this
is starting to become an issue somebody
had asked how you know well
it's the frequency
when these businesses come in it's
usually with somebody that they call a
house manager brings in the person who
is then the translator for this person
they sign up for that business
and across the board it's been the same
translator for we now have six of them
with a seventh on the way
um when something happens when they
by chance have an inspection because of
a fire alarm or whatever the issue is a
lot of times we find that they live in
there their food is delivered to them
they have no means to leave
and what will happen is the fire
department will issue a violation they
will have to shut down in almost like
clockwork the very next week they will
come in with a new owner
um with their translator and this
happens over and over again in most
cases at least once a year
um in one of our recent cases three
times in one year
one place
um somebody asked about
consensual I'm going to go a little bit
deeper and say that in Dairy our zoning
doesn't allow for money for sex it just
doesn't and I don't think the state does
either so
um I I just that's not something that I
want to dig into but anyway
um local police have no authority to
just go in and inspect any of these
businesses without a complaint and I I
don't think you're going to hear many
calls come in from people that had a bad
experience at an illicit massage
establishment it just doesn't happen
the calls that we do get are from
concerned citizens in one case we have a
condo development that backs up to one
of these establishments where we've
gotten calls that the women that live
there
um are doing laundry in a bucket in the
back and hanging out their clothing
washing pots and pans on the back deck
these are people that can't leave
and these are businesses that are open
till 10 11 at night for for what reason
um and
one one of the calls that we got
recently was because there was a lawn
sign out with a phone number that a
citizen had reversed looked up the phone
number and found a Litany of illegal
Services being offered under that
establishment with that phone number
without shop licensure
there there's nothing we can do to go in
and regulate that with shop licensure
when these businesses turn over when
they come in with a new person to sign
up and say that they are the new owner
of a business there has to be a bill of
sale there has to be a new inspection
that will help us it will help prevent
it from growing
so really what I'm looking for is for
this to pass to help me prevent it I
don't want to be in a position where
we're policing and especially for
legitimate businesses and I will say
I've talked to a lot of our legitimate
massage establishment owners who would
welcome shop licensure because it gives
them legitimacy over some of the illicit
businesses
um the last thing I want to touch on is
with putting this in place would save a
ton of money for the taxpayers
especially in my town where I have sex
it takes dozens of hours of the time of
our health inspector our code inspector
our fire inspector my office the
planning office everybody who's involved
in tracing and going through this change
of use system
it's a lot of time it's a lot of running
around only to do it sometimes three
months later
it's very frustrating so I'm here to ask
you to please please consider passing
this legislation
thank you oh also I do have some letters
here
um from the Town Administrator our code
enforcement director as well as myself
and I'm not sure who you would like me
representative Schmidt is there to take
care of it for you okay thank you so
much for your time
um
thank you thank you for Testimony there
may be questions are there any questions
representative a bear
thank you director Donovan for your
testimony today
um my my question
um for you is
if
speaking about the fact that it this
bill would bring that beginning part of
the paperwork and the licensure and
would give you a little bit more control
are there any
changes to an ordinance such as living
quarters
in other words if I were to if I know
that somebody's living in a zoning a
place of business I would call the fire
department the fire department can take
over from there so
it's already against our ordinances to
live in a commercial property it is
but we usually don't find that out until
something else happens for example a
fire alarm goes off and a building needs
to be reinspected that's when we find
those things out otherwise it's hearsay
and you law enforcement won't can't do
anything because somebody said I think
someone lives in there you have to know
someone's living in there
otherwise it would be harassment
and our police chief is 100 percent
behind this passage of this as well as
other Chiefs that um he has spoken to
and
it's an important piece
thank you representative Gerhart
thank you madam chair I mean I believe
the Bill's intentions are noble but I
mean the opposition at least on emails
has been pretty heavy so the the concern
I have always is it that hard to find
someone that speaks Chinese to solicit
these services to go into these
establishments to then figure out what's
going on and then just to be done with
it I just I don't I'm misunderstanding
the the um
well I guess I would ask what would the
authority to do that be
they have their translator I can have an
app on my phone I have done that gone in
and just to say hello as I do with many
other businesses in town
um but
you can't just go in there and inspect a
business no more than you could do a
bead shop or so on just because you feel
like going in there to inspect follow
please well I mean with let's say crack
houses trap houses where we want to call
them you go in there say hey can I have
some crack they give it to you and then
you arrest them for said service do you
know what I mean I don't see why that
couldn't be done I'm just confused here
uh well I guess under what Authority
just because you think you know
something doesn't mean that you do know
something so it would be considered
harassment to go in and do something
like that
and I'm sure probably Homeland Security
or if if the police chief would hear
they they could go into that I'm not in
law enforcement myself but I know that
we have met with several agencies over
the past several years including
Homeland Security multiple agencies to
try to figure this out and what the best
option for us always as it comes up is
prevention
and prevention in the sense that if you
require shop licensure
then that's an opportunity for the oplc
to go in there at the get-go and license
that shop when that shop goes out of
business or sells then that happens
again and you have another opportunity
to go in there and I won't get into the
details of what when these types of
things have happened but
it you know it results in in people
either moving on or
you know closing up and bringing in the
new owner
follow-up last follow-up well wouldn't
prevention also consist of dealing with
members of the community who are
um
frequenting these establishments I mean
wouldn't that kind of play into it just
dealing with that issue and bringing
that to the Forefront of the community
hey you know guys it's not a good idea
maybe we should discuss this and or is
it people from outside the community or
is it it's a little of everything and I
I will say you know from an economic
development standpoint
um in certain areas strip malls where
these occur I have had calls from the
neighboring businesses too that are very
concerned because they see the
trafficking one actually did decide one
summer day to sit out in a lawn chair in
front and say to every person who walked
by hey how is it in there
just to deter it but they shouldn't be
in that position these establishments
should not be able to hurt the
neighboring establishments
thank you other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you so much Charlie Pendle
Pendle bonding
I'm getting all the names wrong today
Kendall Brewery
excuse me no worries
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Charlie pendleberry
I'm a detective with the Merrimack
County Sheriff's Office and I was
fortunate enough to be a member of the
New Hampshire human trafficking task
force and investigate uh both sex and
labor trafficking
as already discussed by rack pazanka
these cases have proved to be very
difficult and I just really want to
reinforce and Echo what he's already
been said I think a lot of the important
points have been touched upon and
discussed but
um representative Gould you um you asked
about basically state law correct so I
wanted to touch on uh about two points
with a New Hampshire state law
um state law enforcement has two rsas at
our disposal basically for this New
Hampshire RSA 6337 which deals with
trafficking in persons and then New
Hampshire RSA 6452 which is prostitution
and such related offenses
uh the issue is is that this would mean
we would have to criminally charge the
workers
who are believed to be victims of
trafficking in these cases and as
already discussed with the
victim-centered approach we do not want
to be charging victims of human
trafficking with prostitution
um it's counter-intuitive
and potentially harmful to the
individual
therefore again as it really touched
upon our goals to hold the person
profiting accountable
if this can be done under New Hampshire
RSA 645 to the Penalty is only a
misdemeanor and there's low
accountability
um however excuse me are you saying that
that running an illicit house of
prostitution is a misdemeanor that's a
misdemeanor ma'am yes unless there's an
element of human trafficking involved
which again
is are really our whole goal to try to
establish and as already discussed it's
proven extremely difficult so for
facilitating a place under your control
for the purposes of prostitution the
penalty is only misdemeanor
thank you very much yep
and um and again we've already discussed
whether reluctant reluctant to come
forward and work with police and I don't
believe it should be the victim's
responsibility to stop the abuse they
are experiencing
um
there needs to be more than just the
criminal justice system to augment these
investigations and hold those profiting
accountable
again I just really want to reinforce
and Echo what was already said but I'm
open to any questions to try to answer
them thank you representative Dolan and
then Gould
thank you madam chair and thank you for
your testimony and the hard work that
you are pursuing
very sympathetic to the lady from Derry
uh her story I served
uh two decades
as a town counselor in Londonderry and
being a sister Community ran across
human trafficking uh several times and
uh I am getting to a question it is um
one of the most heartbreaking things you
can see is when these teenagers
in some cases pre-teens
are brought forth from this environment
and that that they're lost in they don't
know what to do in
um and my question to you is what is
your experience show is what happens uh
to these folks that are
are found out or are are accused of
human trafficking uh
are they punished by their excuse me
representative Dolan that's a
fascinating question but I'm not sure
it's entirely relevant to the to the
billing question
do you think it is uh well I
I'm kind of I'm kind of working my way
towards all of us so question then the
question is uh
how how do you manage
the victims that find themselves in this
environment uh and you know especially
the teens and preteens
well again sir I want to be honest I
have no experience with uh dealing with
juveniles and these type of
establishments so I can't speak
intelligently on that but
I'm sorry I lost my train of thought for
a minute but um
I mean the
severity for the crime of human
trafficking would be substantial if it
can be established and that is our goal
whether at the state level which would
be a felony or at the federal level
which you know the repercussions are
substantial but again getting their
Improvement it's extremely difficult so
thank you
thank you um
um I and I think maybe other people may
have some questions which aren't
directly on topic but if you could hang
around a little bit after the hearing
maybe we could deal with them then
rather than drag this off thanks
okay represent Gerhard and then gold
thank you madam chair
so the victims thank you for coming
today the victims we're not trying to
charge or you don't want to be charging
the victims for these offenses but isn't
that the whole premise of the drug war
catch a small fish lead you to the big
fish wasn't that the whole concept not
that the drug war is a success but I'm
just saying wasn't that the isn't that
the premise
I mean again I understand what you're
saying but I'm a little confused by that
and how that really applies here I mean
I
you're right I'm testifying to state law
enforcement officer but are you asking
me again investigative questions
uh I yes representative Garner I think
it may be that in the case of a business
like this the business owner is at least
the medium-sized fish is already there
if that's correct
so follow up
well the just the concept of
establishing guilt or you know it just
seems that so you have the lowest person
that you couldn't technically catch
easily you call these establishments we
go in there not we I'm not going to but
you go in there and you disestablish the
crime has been committed then you're
saying that these people at the lowest
levels will not turn on the people at
the next highest level oh and that's the
thing and as I was saying I mean
charging them could just put them in
Harm's Way for multiple reasons right
and and yes I don't think even putting a
misdemeanor charge on them what why
would that be enough for them to flip it
it's just a fine right it could be the
price of doing business it's not enough
for them to you know put themselves in
harm way and and rat out who's ever
trafficking them I don't believe so
thank you representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
coming in and testifying I apologize
that I I wrote the two rsas down and I
can read them later but then in your
subsequent testimony
um is it so is it is what I'm hearing
that you don't have a loss specifically
against trafficking no there is a law
633 7 but okay but but again really
there to to dumb it down we need a
commercial sex act with an element of
force fraud or coercion and in a massage
parlor we would need that element of
force voter coercion coming from the
victim okay and as and as discussed we
can't Pierce that it's just you know
what whatever that element may be right
one of those three things yes they're a
little broad but I understand my social
work background is in Juvenile Justice
with adolescent females so I totally get
all that
um so you have a law but this is going
to help you in terms of Licensing so
that as I'm understand it it gives you
the cause for I'm sorry follow-up Madam
chair yes thank you madam
this gives you the cause to go into the
establishment is that the deal if
they're not licensed I'm not using this
to go into an establishment my thought
process is is that this would just help
regulate these businesses right it would
give you know we would know who worked
there it would prevent a consistent
rotation of workers potentially
do you know what I mean I'm not asking
to use this for law enforcement purposes
I just think it could be beneficial to
victims of human trafficking thank you
one more follow-up promise less
in my experience in church in foster
care or Residential Care where you're
worried about perpetrators uh taking
children in and abusing them
I find that uh
my experience has been that a perp will
jump through any hoop but law-abiding
citizens get to a point where they say
enough
and so you don't have I don't want to
lose my ability to get a massage I don't
want to see massage therapists harassed
by regulations that are unnecessary
unless I know how this is going to help
and to me my concern is about well I can
talk about that later that goes beyond
um
so um thank you thank you for your
testimony yourself yes thank you ma'am
all right any other questions
right
thank you very much for your testimony
and uh
all right
uh Pamela kilig and Meg chant
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee
the committee my name is Alyssa dandria
and I'm the community relations
specialist for the Coalition
um Coalition uh the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence uh Pamela Kylie had to go to
another hearing room so I'm stepping in
for her this afternoon or this morning
may I approach with the new card and
also my contact information do you have
that I will pick that up at the end time
okay thank you Coalition for all right
against domestic against against
Domestic and Sexual Violence
um we also have copies of Our Testimony
which will provide the committee at the
end as well
so the Coalition is the umbrella
Organization for this uh States 12
community-based crisis centers which
serve uh victims of Domestic and Sexual
Violence stalking and human trafficking
we provide free and confidential
services to about 15 000 victims every
year
I'm here today to support HB 341
legislation that would establish for
massage parlors I'm joined by my
colleague Meg chant who is the human
trafficking specialist at the Coalition
um she's here today to provide
information about how this legislation
would positively impact our state and
our response to human trafficking thank
you for the opportunity to testify today
and I'll let Meg continue
good morning for the record my name is
Meg Chan I'm the human trafficking
project specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence and in this role I serve as the
Director of the New Hampshire human
trafficking collaborative task force
which is a multi-disciplinary
partnership between law enforcement
agencies prosecutors Health Care
Professionals Children's Services victim
services and Community Partners
throughout the state I'm going to skip a
little bit of the human trafficking
background I was going to give because
some of our colleagues have done that we
would appreciate it yes I do want to
just highlight the question from
representative Gould earlier though that
the victims that we see around the state
are all ages genders demographics as are
the perpetrators so it's not a specific
immigration issue or anything like that
the Polaris project which operates the
national human trafficking hotline
created the term illicit massage
business to describe a very specific
type of exploitative organized
commercial front trafficking venue that
they saw implicated over and over again
in cases reported to their National
hotline so that term doesn't Encompass
legal therapeutic massage businesses nor
does it include consensual sex work that
may incorporate massage
while we know that it's not the sole
purpose of the bill the Coalition
believes that this bill would help to
address the growing problem of illicit
massage businesses in New Hampshire so
oplc can speak more broadly to why this
bill is essential but we are here on to
talk about the human trafficking element
the task force has identified more than
50 such businesses in our state to date
it's very difficult like officer
pendlebury said to initiate a human
trafficking investigation in these
situations because the trafficking
prosecution relies so heavily on victim
input and in the absence of a stable
secure victim by which I mean a victim
who is and feels safe from their
trafficker it's nearly impossible to
gather that information about their
trafficker to bring the case
it's a priority of the Coalition in
partnership with the task force to
connect as many victims and survivors as
possible with the services that can help
to raise them out of Crisis the
Coalition and our crisis center is aim
to provide access to robust
trauma-informed victim-centered services
for all victims of human trafficking
this necessitates Outreach to victims
who may not realize that help is
available and that the abuse and
exploitation of their suffering actually
meet the definition of human trafficking
we know that these businesses are
operating around the state and that
victims in these situations are
carefully controlled and monitored by
their traffickers with very little
opportunity to seek help let alone to
research what options might be available
to them traffickers like previous
testimonies have said traffickers exert
a massive amount of control over their
victims
so they may be immigrants they may not
be but traffickers can exploit social
and cultural norms a relative lack of
contacts and familiarity familiarity
with local resources
as well as
by telling that you know traffickers can
express to victims that they are
committing a crime of prostitution or
related crimes and that if they report
that or if they seek help they will be
prosecuted themselves and that's you
know like people have said already
that's not what we want to do we want to
stabilize victims and get them to safety
it's critical that we find every
opportunity to counter these dangerous
messages and meet victims where they are
so this legislation would create another
way for victims to be identified and
offered Services if we can have informed
professionals making contact with these
victims at the point of licensure checks
we have an opportunity to connect with
them to offer services and correct
correct misconceptions about
vulnerability to prosecution and removal
so this we see this as an opportunity to
offer someone a safe supported pathway
out of their trafficking situation and
connect them to the many services and
resources that are available to them via
the coalitions 12 Regional Crisis
centers
thank you thank you are there any any
specific questions
okay I think we've worn ourselves out
thank you for your testimony
good morning Madam chair uh in honorable
committee members I do have written
testimony so we'll keep representative
Schmidt busy today
um so my name is Michael Porter I'm the
investigations bureau chief with the
office of professional licensure and
certification
uh I do you'll have my written testimony
I really want to highlight the aspects
of this bill what this bill does
what this bill does it's first of all
it's one piece of a very large puzzle
um this bill provides an ability to
inspect massage establishments
proactively
it reduces the disruption to legitimate
businesses legitimate massage therapy
businesses
um and in other businesses uh that are
operating in the vicinity of these other
establishments that are hosting
unlicensed practice of Massage Therapy
this bill assists in the protection of
the public health safety and Welfare
this bill protects legitimate
therapeutic massage business owners uh
who are operating legally from those who
are not
this bill reinforces public confidence
that an establishment and a licensee and
or licensee within uh they're Meeting
those minimum health and safety
requirements
those are some of the the key factors of
this bill right now we currently do not
have the ability to go in and
proactively investigate
with other licensing boards we do other
professions where we can go in we can
inspect
I want to assure something to this
committee right now and I've heard the
question asked we're not calling Mike
and Charlie saying hey come out and do
an inspection with us and if we find
something you can move in that is not
what's happening we already have
statutes on the books that allow us when
we are doing a regulatory investigation
if we determine this criminal activity
we already have the authority to go and
reach out to law enforcement and provide
them with the evidence that we've seen
as the current legislation that is
enacted today we license the LA we only
license the licensees not the
establishment where they work
so when we get a complaint that comes in
because we have to we're reactive not
proactive
we will send inspectors out and I have
personally this year made it a point to
go out myself with other investigators I
can't get into all the details of the
investigations but let me give you some
highlights
we approach a building it's in a strip
mall there's other businesses operating
in order to gain entry you have to hit a
buzzer
they look through their camera they see
who we are and they either refuse to
open the door
um whether they do it verbally which has
been done or they just don't open it
other times we've called in we've said
hey are you open
oh yeah we're open come out the back I
was like no we're gonna go in the front
oh we're closed
okay
these are two incidents we also had we
had a person and I don't want to get
into too many details on this who
legitimately who believed he was
visiting a legitimate massage parlor
until he got inside and things happened
and money was demanded from him and he
paid it because he didn't know it was on
the other side of that door he paid it
those are situations that we're running
into now we can go in and we can attempt
to identify who the unlicensed parties
are
but they don't have to allow us in and
when we do go in we don't know if we're
getting the right name I in in some
instances in one particular case I was
given four different names I don't know
who the person was I couldn't identify
that person
when we left
we had no Avenue by which to even
attempt to close this business down
because if they had an establishment
license we could do a memo for the board
highlight what happened and let the
board determine if there are if this
business
posed an imminent danger to public
health safety or welfare and if it did
they would have the ability to
immediately shut down the establishment
we could then notify law enforcement and
if that establishment opens up again
without being licensed they're in
violation
we're coming at this from a pure
regulatory perspective any ancillary
issues that occur as a result of that
that's not something that we're looking
for
um
but I I do want to let this committee
know as far as
I've heard questions about ordinances as
compared to licensure laws and and I
agree ordinances are fine if they're
enforced and enacted the problem is the
courts today especially the district
courts don't take they really don't
enforce the violation level ordinances
police departments are overrun with
other serious calls that they have to
respond to and if they're responding to
ordinance violations it ties up those
units and those services
the fact of the matter is if this is
under a licensure an establishment
licensure and you can look at our
website and you can see some of the
emergency suspensions that we have
issued across the board for various
professions
if the board determines that there's an
imminent danger to the public health
safety or welfare because we regulate
that that business we can actually the
board can actually issue an emergency
order now they do have due process that
due process requires a hearing within 10
days they can get that hearing
oftentimes what happens is we enter into
a preliminary agreement not to practice
pending the outcome of the investigation
but these are some of the highlights
that that we have that this bill brings
forward
um and you know an ordinance would not
solve the immediacy and if we're dealing
with people in consumers who are
actually today being harmed
we can't wait 6 8 10 12 weeks for an
ordinance to violation to be tracked
through the court system it should have
a regulatory body which is us where the
board would hear the facts and make a
decision with that I'll be happy to
answer any questions if anybody has any
I I have two actually uh
so if I do I understand you correctly
that you expect
a illicit business to not be able to get
a license in the first place
I don't know that we would I you're
asking me a hypothetical on something
that we just don't know the answer to
yet because
when they apply for the license
um it'll depend on what their
application says and depending on what
they're okay
and but it you you do expect that if a
complaint was received for from a
illicit establishment you
you would be able to enter without their
permission
and shut them down immediately
or possibly the short board visit
inventory right so I want to make sure
we're not going and kicking indoors so
what happens we would go in for example
and say we would like to come inspect
they could still refuse us but that
would be a violation against their
license we would then file that with the
board and pull them in for a hearing I
just want to make sure that this statute
doesn't give us the authority to just
barge in I think it's still tell us no
but now we have teeth
thank you
um any other representative Simon thank
you madam chair just by way of
clarification this is obviously uh seems
like a different sort of bill because
two very obvious things are overlapping
with each other we're asking to
um create a license for an establishment
um and we're also trying to combat a
separate sort of crime at the same time
um and I would kind of relate it to it
would be like if we were going to
license food service industry people but
at the same time we're looking for money
laundering
um and so I guess my main question is
we have two things that we're targeting
but we have one inspector going in and
as that inspector also supposed to be an
expert in identifying trafficking
um in order to bring that information
out uh so that we can then look at that
situation and and pursue the Avenues
that you're talking about because we
just have one inspector but we're really
trying to accomplish two things at the
same time and that's a great question uh
so as far as being an expert no I think
a lot of it would depend on what they
see when they go in so if they if they
were to go in and see let's say
something that appeared to be out of the
ordinary that they would come back and
report that to myself or the division
director who's here and we would talk
about it it's not like it would be an
immediate call to law enforcement it may
be something that's innocuous it may be
something that's nothing they wouldn't
be an expert per se but I think that uh
this really comes down to accountability
right now there's no accountability and
if we have the establishment licensure
we can absolutely hold that that
business owner or establishment owner
accountable
through the investigation process we may
learn that there's criminal activity and
we will definitely report that out to
law enforcement and other other Health
licensing agencies as well so I hope
that answers but no we're not going to
be experts follow
um right so I mean one of the things
that we're going to have to balance as
we're looking at this obviously we want
accountability right but we're balancing
accountability with harassment and and
no matter what we do the risk of both is
present right I mean we could overstep
our bounds and harass somebody innocent
or vice versa and so once again we're
looking at a particular person as being
the kind of the spearhead of that
operation and that person is an
inspector it's for massage
establishments it's not an inspector for
looking for illicit
businesses correct correct so how from
your perspective how do you really
thread that needle
well
it is a difference and I'm sympathetic
to obviously I you know I want
trafficking to stop so I'm not saying
you know no I understand and I think
it's important to understand uh from our
perspective when we look at this so we
have that inspector who goes in to do a
random inspection we don't have to wait
for a complaint so we don't have to wait
for the Post action we we can try to be
uh proactive
they're going and looking for health and
safety code violations to make sure that
they're properly set up that you know if
they're and I don't know what those are
those haven't been fully flushed out and
I'm not an expert on that so uh the the
key here is to determine whether they
meet those minimum safety requirements
if other things are happening and they
observe it then they will bring that
back to us and we'll we'll discuss it
but no their primary function is
regulatory not criminal investigation
okay okay thank you other questions
yes represent a bear
thank you for your testimony
I just have one last question and that
is
is there anything in your enforcement
regulations currently or audits that you
could increase without this lobbying
enacted
with specifically with massage
uh itself yes right now we don't have
the ability to do any inspections until
we receive a complaint so
even if we do the investigation and or
inspection and like I said I've been
part of those this year I've made it an
effort to do so
if if we're refused entry there's just
nothing we can do and we receive these
calls from towns across the state uh
Londonderry Dairy and then up in the
north country and they're frustrated and
so unless we have that ability to
actually inspect
there's very little little to nothing
that we can do yeah okay
interesting thank you other questions
I'm I was actually incredibly
disheartened to hear you say that the
circuit courts and the police don't
enforce our ordinances because it seems
to me that we're band-aiding a new law
on top of an existing law that is not
enforced and I have some very deep
philosophical objections to that and I
think it's it's not
you know and I want to be very very
clear here it's also the speed by which
action can occur right if you if you do
an ordinance violation that goes through
the court system even if it is enforced
through the courts it's going to take a
long time
by issuing an establishment license if
we run into a situation that requires
the immediacy
imminent danger to the public health
safety and Welfare we have the ability
to take action immediately and then
within 10 days they can have their
hearing so even if an ordinance
violation is brought before the courts
by the time that works itself through
the system we've already taken action
regulatory wise thank you thank you any
other questions representative true
thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
so let this build massage therapist
already are licensed and what this bill
would do would establish
a business
uh over a facility that has massage
therapists working at correct
follow up thank you madam chair
so
how would you go about determining that
uh
a business that has massage tables in it
empty
is harmful to the Public Health and
Welfare
that's a great question so the first
thing we would do is check to make sure
that those who are slated to be working
there are actually licensed that's the
very first step that we would look at so
the establishment licensure would allow
our our inspector to go in
and determine who is licensed and if we
determine that there are three licensees
in our database that that are working
there and they have uh six
right we have a problem we have to
figure out who's licensed who's not
anytime an unlicensed party conducts any
type of profession it erodes at the
safety of that profession those
professionals who who obtained
professional licensure have met the
minimum requirements of health and
safety so first thing we look for is
licensed versus unlicensed
thank you other question yes
representative Gould
so I'm confused are there currently a
requirement that massage therapists are
licensed oh yeah sure absolutely okay
thank you
um
yes indeed you know all the massage
there therapists are licensed yes or
should be
any other questions
thank you very much Mr Porter make sure
you'll be supporting our subcommittee
yes
does any other member of the public wish
to testify on House Bill 341.
all right seeing none
I'll close the hearing send it to the
licensing subcommittee
and open the hearing on House Bill 105.
thank you ah
okay
okay thank you representative Broda
um
thank you madam chair
I'm representative Jackie excuse me
representative could the people still
wanted to talk about massage
establishments please step into the
hallway
thank you representative Grote thank you
my name is Jackie grota I represent
Rockingham 24 and I'm here to introduce
house bill 105.
relative to the registration of May
spons I think I have some good news for
the committee on this bill I'm hoping
um we we changed this bill last year for
future work
and we've since learned that finally
when we filed this bill
we did receive several
uh comments from professional advocacy
groups that are interested in the
legislation
based on this in the testimony that
you'll hear today I ask you that you
retain this bill so that we can address
all the concerns through either an
amended bill or rulemaking so I asked
I'm asking the committee to retain the
Bill thank you and I will not answer
questions all right
thank you I would I will say that I
agree with retaining this bill because
it does have a lot of open concerns
uh Tanya Lawson
good morning Madame chairman art
chairwoman and members of the committee
my name is Dr Tanya Lawson I'm a
licensed naturopathic doctor in New
Hampshire and I've been practicing here
since 2015. I've been in practice for 16
years primarily in the industry of
Medical Aesthetics
I own and operate In Bloom health and
Medi Spa in Londonderry New Hampshire
and I currently serve as co-president of
amp NH which is aesthetic medical
providers of New Hampshire we are a
non-profit organization that represents
medical providers in the industry and
currently our group
entails doctors nurses Nurse
Practitioners dentists and physician
assistants
currently we represent almost half the
medical spas in the state
we've submitted an official statement of
position regarding this bill and we do
not support the legislation as written
however we have had several productive
conversations and meetings with the oplc
representative groda and Madame
chairwoman and look forward as serving a
resource to help protect patients in
this industry and we would like to thank
the representatives for including our
feedback in this legislation and we do
look forward to working on it further
with you
thank you
questions
seeing noneth
thank you very much thank you
Daniel Keady
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee uh my name is Daniel Katie
I'm the chief administrative officer for
our Katy Medical Group
I'm here today to provide my conditional
support for the bill and uh to provide a
testimony
first of all about who I am where I come
from Katie Medical Group is a new
hampshire-based company uh the handouts
that you were provided there's a cover
page and that's the conditional support
um so Katie Medical Group is a new
hampshire-based company providing
Medical Services to New Hampshire
citizens since 2012. we operate five
locations throughout the state of New
Hampshire some of the services that we
provide and we've been very gracious to
provide have been the kova 19
vaccinations in conjunction with DHHS
um you'll see us around our purple vans
uh and then We additionally have provide
direct clinical oversight to the 14
Regional public health networks for the
State of New Hampshire
additionally we have a primary health
care clinics in medically underserved
communities
and college Health Care lastly we do
Workplace Health Clinics and Medical
Aesthetics which are all done by our
highly trained personnel
in addition Katy Medical Group has
licensed medical professionals on staff
and are available should an emergency
ever occur
to touch on
my conditional support of the bill Katy
Medical Group believes that the Bill's
intentions are indeed to create a safe
environment for all patients seeking
aesthetic care however there is a large
group of providers that are left out of
this bill physician assistants or PAs
do provide care throughout the city of
New Hampshire in many different settings
and Specialties they offer a wide array
of Knowledge and Skills in training in
the medical Fields they've helped
alleviate a shortage of medical
providers throughout the years
especially throughout the pandemic that
we had experience at Dartmouth many
other hospitals we're very fortunate to
have Pas in that regard
and currently the regular the
regulations already do exist and dictate
the parameters of how Pas are permitted
to practice directly through the Board
of Medicine
uh we can definitely practice and kitty
Medical Group does not find it necessary
to add additional restrictions to the
natures of how Pas can practice since
this has already been ruled in the past
in various other fields and Specialties
within medicine in the state of New
Hampshire
um and specifically on the cover page
you'll see a highlighted portion that
portion there is the portion of the bill
um that is uh I request an amendment on
um it's our belief that Pas need to be
excluded from these restrictions and
that the policy conforms to the current
medical standard of other Medical
Specialties until the wording has been
amended in the bill to exclude ppas from
these increased restrictions uh kidney
Medical Group cannot fully support this
bill we agree with all the other details
that are within the bill and we ask that
this change to be considered
therefore we do offer our conditional
approval specifically in the highlighted
portion
um
we asked that house bill 105 can include
physician assistance as medical
providers are able to perform the
initial assessment and create the
treatment plan without direct oversight
as previously stated this has already
been covered throughout the scope of Pas
with their supervising positions
and in that layout
um
now to move on so Health spill 105 is a
step in the right direction
for Consumer Protection in the field of
Medical Aesthetics consumer protection
safeguards are desperately needed
in the field of Medical Aesthetics to do
the added risks inherent with the
procedures undertaken in this field
there's a lack of oversight a lack of
transparency in this industry
Medical Aesthetics Remains the last wild
west of the medical community with
little oversight and or training
necessary to perform procedures
inherent to the industry is the
prevalent of off-label use
of many medications therapies and
procedures it is the right of the
medical provider to provide the care
that they best see fit with careful
consultation with the patients with the
associated risks of off label care
however the field of Medical Aesthetics
providers May downplay the risk
associated with many off-label care for
the pursuit for the pursuant of profit
for example vascular occlusion of
hyaluronic acid filler often caused by
an accidental injection of a product
into an artery is rare certainly but
could potentially lead to a serious
complication such as blindness if the
injection is around the orbital region
many aesthetic clinicians are simply not
prepared for such an emergency of this
incident were to occur
and do this lack of medical oversight or
because the procedure is performed in a
non-medical setting
lacking the proper emergency supplies an
injector in the back of the salon May
lack the emergency supplies to remedy
and occlusion an important reminder to
the public is that while the procedures
are aesthetic they are still Medical in
nature and should only be performed in
clinical environments equipped to handle
emergency situations
further oversight is necessary for
Consumer Protection
many medical spas providers advertise
dubious claims about pharmaceutical
procedures and procured from
underregulated compounding pharmacies
compounding pharmacies do certainly
indeed play a great role in this field
in the medical industry
to provide effective medications to
patients however in recent years many
compounding pharmacies with unfavorable
track records with the FDA have sprung
up to cater to the ongoing demand of
this of this ever-growing industry that
being Medical Aesthetics for cheap
medications so there have been numerous
incidents in multiple states of expired
medications being administered on
patients in medical spa settings
the majority of the medical space so
furthermore the majority of medical spas
are inactive of non-compliance with
Federal Regulations relating to the no
surprise Act
many Medical Spa clinics do not display
their pricing before patients receive a
treatment in most cases the cost of
treatment is not known until after the
treatment has been performed under
federal law medical providers are
required to provide at least a good
faith estimate of the cost of treatment
in the state of New Hampshire
more moreover in many states medical
spas fails to inform patients of the
cost of the treatments
in many cases the cost of treatments can
be thousands of dollars which is quite a
bit for a person to endure it
additionally instances using laser
Technologies by untrained non-medical
professionals are going unchecked the
dangers of lasers are immense and can
cause irreparable irreversible damage to
a patient including blindness permanent
damage
most of these issues prevalent in the
medical spa industry can be resolved if
there was closer relationship between
medical spas in the existing medical
establishment the existing medical
establishment says policies and
procedures in place to protect these
patients the existing medical
establishment also insists on having
medical providers on premises for the
safety of the patients the relative
costs that would be borne by the
industry would only slightly diminish
the high margins
prevalent in the industry and would be
offset by the greater consumer trusts in
the industry in conclusion
Katy Medical Group supports House Bill
105 as a step in the right direction for
Consumer safety
thank you very much
questions
okay thank you I'm I'm sure the
subcommittee will be considered will
like to talk to you as necessary thank
you for your time okay
David cuzzy
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
David cuzzy with Prospect Hill
strategies here in Concord uh here this
morning this afternoon now on behalf of
the New Hampshire Society of physician
assistants or nispa or simply the Pas
the previous speaker I think
said most of what I was going to say
probably better than I so I appreciate
that
um but I am here on behalf of the 1000
or so Pas here in New Hampshire I've had
uh good conversations with
representative Rhoda we're looking
forward to being active participants in
the uh subcommittee and any further
discussions uh as previously noted of
course we were unintentionally excluded
uh in the bill members of the committee
who were here last term remember that
the Pas had Senate Bill 228 which
introduced which modernized the PA
practice brought the statutes and regs
in line with more tradition more modern
Uh current uh practicing of medicine and
that included changes to the terminology
so the terminology of like a responsible
physician is now a collaborating
physician things along those lines this
uh unintendedly would have rolled a lot
of that progress back we we appreciate I
did send in on behalf of the Pas a
suggested Amendment where physician
assistance could be added as appropriate
of course we'll work on that I think I
thank you for hearing me briefly and
happy to take any questions if any
thank you representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair welcome back to
the chair
um so sir
um
um first of all
are you going to be available for the
sub
yeah absolutely if if not me we'll have
uh one of the Pas available it's it's
difficult with all the the busyness
within the Healthcare Community to get
someone here but will absolutely be be
participating yes representative okay
follow up so uh I I I've had several
serious uh medical procedures and very
often they have involved at some point
in the procedure
uh pas okay so I know that they have a
very high level of Medical Training
compared and aprns also uh can have
Advanced Training uh and can do many
things that doctors used to do
exclusively okay so uh it seems to me
that it's it's inherent that when you're
doing things involving injections uh
that you have to have people with a high
level of background training this is
where my question is going to because
untoward circumstances can occur and you
you need to have the high level training
in order to be able to deal with
untoward events is that not correct that
you can't get with somebody who has no
substantial medical training thank you
for the question representative yes that
that's correct and PAs uh of course they
would they are only allowed to practice
uh according to their education training
and and any other uh pertinent
sub-specialty training yes
thank you thank you other other
questions
all right seeing none
um does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 105.
all right
seeing none I'm closing the public
hearing and opening the executive
session without objection representative
grotta
you have a motion yes Madam chair I
mooch retain house bill 105.
I'll second that
okay you wish to speak to your motion
okay
um
well if you want do you want to speak to
him I think representative schuette
wanted to retain the bill so she'll make
the motion if I will draw mine thank you
sure it makes the motion all right then
would you like to speak to your motion
darn I wanted to
representative shewitt
just hearing that
um both are
Democratic leader and the chair feel
that the proper thing to do with this
Phil is retain it and since we've heard
that it does need a little work I think
it's an appropriate motion
and I'd like to speak to my second
because
there are some concerns I am not at all
convinced that the approach this bill
takes is the correct one but it doesn't
it's possible and it does need some work
before we seriously consider it
any other comments questions
all right seeing none those in favor of
retaining House Bill 105 will vote I and
those opposed will vote in a and the
clerk can call the rule
representative Simon
stepped out
representative blakis yes representative
Bailey yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Weber yes representative Gerhard yes
the clerk votes yes
representative groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the chair yes
and we got sorry one two
16 yay zero and a
okay the emotion passes it is retained
and uh for your benefits representative
shewitt a report is not required at this
time
all right we we will break for lunch we
are back at one sorry but uh
thank you
we will resume at 1 30.
foreign
the speaker has decided that we will not
be shutting down tomorrow so we will be
having our hearings as scheduled
and I would hope as many of you as can
make it will be here with me
otherwise it'll get lonely
all right
and I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 620 and I call Representative Heath
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Mary Sullivan Heath
and I represent District 41 Wards 2 4 5
and 7 in the city of Manchester and I
also want to preface my remarks um by
letting you know we have a member of our
Manchester School Board here today Sean
Parr and they have
um made as a priority preschool
education in the city of Manchester and
that's one of the reasons why I
submitted this bill as well as
numerous meetings around the
conversation beginning a pilot program
for three and four-year-olds
so let me begin
as an educational administrator I worked
at the department I was a teacher I a
special education teacher assistant
superintendent and over the years I've
worked with hundreds of children going
into kindergarten and we usually would
do an early childhood assessment as they
came into kindergarten so we could
prepare their program and we saw very
clearly that those children who had had
some kind of a high quality preschool
experience always performed at a much
higher level
this 50 years of research that supports
that
so it's the goal of House Bill 620 to
work toward offering three and
four-year-old children a high quality
pre-kindergarten learning opportunity
within an executive branch Department of
early childhood
we believe every child should have an
opportunity to achieve at high levels
this is not only a moral imperative but
it's essential to our economic success
and societal well-being I also am
working on an international study
committee with ncsl we spent the last
two years reviewing countries around the
world that achieve at really high levels
on the Pisa
and we found a pattern within all of
these one of the first things that
they've done is they've promoted Early
Childhood programs for children and that
has
that's aligned with their study of
curriculum and it has and of course
professional development for the
teachers that goes along with that but
they've found a strong
correlation between early childhood
education and long-term student
achievement
God bless you
hb620 establishes an executive branch
Department of early childhood education
and also establishes the Authority for
the Department to design create and
administer a three-year high-quality
community-based mixed delivery public
pre-kindergarten pilot program
I emailed all of my testimony to you so
I won't read it word for word thank you
yes but in preparation
um for this meeting I do want you to
know the careful consideration and the
communication that we had with the
preschool community so there is a lot
going on the commissioner of Education
of Deputy Commissioner of education has
been working with many groups with
regard to this area as well and so I'm
sure she's here to answer any questions
you might have to her too as well so New
Hampshire is only one of Six States the
previous information in the bill says
seven states but since then
um States like Colorado States like New
Mexico actually New Mexico has just
passed one of the most aggressive
preschool opportunities and access for
preschool education in the country
so furthermore early care and education
is critical for our Working Families it
it's during covid so many women were
pulled out of the workforce they weren't
able to work the number of Early
Childhood
um
uh placements
uh were lessened because of the fact of
of covid and the difficulty of
everything going on and so we we were in
this strange place right now where
things are getting better but there's
still repercussions from that
so
hb620 will work toward offering three
and four-year-old children a high
quality pre-kindergarten experience and
the formation of the Early Childhood Pro
Department to guide that pilot which I
think is critical uh just to let you
know I used to be
um Deputy Commissioner at the New
Hampshire Department of Education and
one of my conundrums during the time I
worked at the department was that things
relative to preschool education would
come up
and the Department of Education has
absolutely no authority over anything
beyond kindergarten through age 12. so
it was this kind of this gray area
because we also had of the special
education preschool grant money that
came through us so there was an
awkwardness to it so I'm hoping that um
hb620 will take us to a different place
and um we'll you will consider this
opportunity it's so important for
children in my city of Manchester to
have high quality for all of them to
have a high quality access to programs
and to benefit from that program I think
there are so many people that would
benefit from it but I am happy to
entertain questions
thank you
um I have one question
major organization initiatives like this
generally succeed or fail with the
governor's support have you gotten
support from the governor
um
we have had conversations with
hb620 is also being introduced as a
Senate bill in the other body and there
are members that have had conversations
we have not had I am not aware that we
have full support from the office of the
governor but I know that there are many
people reaching out to him with regard
to that matter
thank you representative blackis and
then hey bear thank you um you mentioned
um studies that showed the benefit of
this um if you have if you can I'd like
you to send uh at least a link to the
committee to the actual studies not
articles about the studies but the
studies I'd be happy to okay thank you
Madam chair
thank you for your testimony today
I am I I like metrics a lot so when I
hear that it will benefit many I I'd
like a definition of many number one and
number two I noticed that this bill is a
fiscal note introduced but I don't see
any monies as of yet thank you it is not
and we have not seen the fiscal note yet
I'm sure though when if it should pass
the house and it gets to fiscal we will
have that note
um we're assuming to set up a department
would probably be a bureau Department
whatever we end up doing
um would probably be about 500 000 the
preschool the three-year preschool pilot
um depending upon the communities we
don't have an exact figure like that uh
just yet but I'm assuming it will be
anywhere between six and ten million
dollars
thank you representative Schmidt and
then Gerhard
thank you madam chair so I'm wondering
over here always thank you
voices coming out of the sky
um
I'm wondering why is it this in front of
Edna and not the education committee
well I asked that question to myself as
well
um did yourself say and myself said to
go and ask someone so I did and I was
told that because this should go to this
committee because it is requesting
um a a separate department or Bureau yes
if they had simply said the Department
of Education will run this pilot program
we wouldn't be involved right
represent gerhardt
I'm trying to find the actual Citation
for it right now thank you madam
the I saw numbers that New Hampshire
actually leads this Co the country with
declining Public School enrollment I
think it's down 14 so
is there any belief that this will be uh
this will succumb to the same
situation where just to be such a you
already said there was a decline because
the kova now slowly picking back up but
if that Trend continues because at least
in Northfield we have a completely open
school building it's just sitting there
vacant right now so any comments on that
aspect the answer is yes New Hampshire
does have declining student School
enrollment
one of the things that I hope that this
bill will promote will be a preschool
program that would also attract young
families from other states to actually
move to the state of New Hampshire New
Hampshire I believe is the second oldest
state
um and we could benefit from attracting
younger people to the state of New
Hampshire we also have a problem with
our younger people going to other states
to live so I think by offering these
kinds of programs we bring more people
in it would attract younger families and
we probably wouldn't be the second
oldest state in the country
I hope you know thank you representative
Simon thank you madam chair um so this
is going to be a three-year pilot
program yes
um
is three years a sufficient amount of
time to gain any understanding of the
success of the program
um I don't know if you remember
um representative Mary Stuart guile
um Mary Stuart geil had submitted a
similar Bill to like this many years ago
the conversation is that a three-year
pilot would indeed give us a good sense
of what would work and again this is a a
mixed
um Community program so each Community
is going to be different and each
program would look a little bit
different so if we're our thought
process is that we'd probably look at
two rural areas and two uh bigger areas
to try out the pilot so we'd get a sense
of what it would look like but we think
that three years is sufficient
um just to clarify the question the
argument is that by providing quality
preschool we're going to see success in
the student over the long term we're
going to get a good result by the end
and whereas you're arguably starting at
the latest age with a four or
five-year-old that brings you to the to
age eight not age 18 so how are we going
to track the long-term benefits of
whether or not that had an impact you
know within the three-year term well
there are lots of different ways to
track the progress of children we have
the New Hampshire State assessment
that's one methodology we have ongoing
local assessments that schools
um apply we also have graduation rates
um the rate at which
students finish High School in four
years the percentage of students going
on to a four-year college so there are
lots of ways they're long it's a
long-term look but there has been a long
term the 50 years actually of long-term
look at at kindergarten programs in
early childhood programs in relation to
Children's success as they enter school
and that they're reading at grade level
by grade three so we do have some
information that would be a strong
indicator of long-term success there are
a lot of factors that happen along the
way for children but in terms of giving
them the best possible start is a good
way to make sure that we're giving them
the highest potential for success over
their school years thank you
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question uh I'm wondering why
you're going to establish its own
separate Department why did you not go
within the Avenue of going under the
Department of Education would that not
have been more efficient to the taxpayer
and also provide a cohesive oversight of
the program as well
well three and four-year-olds don't live
in the department of Ed
um a lot of
issues that relate to them reside in
health and human services
and as I said earlier it's a bit of a
conundrum that the department of
education does not have
Authority for students
their Authority ranges from K through
12.
the Department of Education doesn't have
authority but below that so in
developing its own Bureau or Department
what we have is a unique situation with
children needing the educational
environment and needing some of the
elements of Health and Human Services so
by creating an early childhood
Department which many many states have
done I don't have the exact number with
me right now but I think the Deputy
Commissioner has that information
would be a benefit it would be a focus
on our early childhood children I think
it would be a benefit to the Department
of Ed to Health and Human Services and
parents and school districts
follow up follow up
well I'm a little confusing could you
help me out because I'm thinking it
doesn't already am I correct in saying
that it already exists and
a situation where the child is three
years old been identified as a special
needs student yes and they are accepted
within the educational program yes and
some communities such as in Nashua they
do open it up they do our typical
development yes where and that's a
brilliant way of handling things so I
was under the assumption that it's
already there it's not many school
districts do have an integrated
preschool
many do because there are preschool
special education funds and also under
the federal legislation for No Child
Left Behind
and I'm sorry that's not the legislation
now it's the Essa act and it's under
esea that was passed in 1965.
um under that legislation that is uh
that also allows for funds to be used
for early childhood
so yes in fact that those funds could be
used in that area
follow-up so you're saying like in a
situation of Medicare can be applied
underneath your bill if if the child is
identified as special needs and would
typically uh developmental type of
children that you would reap the
Medicare benefits which would lower your
excuse me representative O'Brien you're
talking Medicaid Medicaid very few
children are over 65. yeah that's true
you know Madam chair thank you so much
I'm over 65 I'm I'm in the block but I'm
sure the representative know what I
meant I still understand what but
actually some we're talking about the
kids with a beard
[Laughter]
um there are children that are eligible
um and they're Regional agencies that
become involved at actually at the if a
child is born with a significant
disability the regional area kicks in at
that time and then when a child is three
the age of three the special ed law
comes into place and that's where the
child is eligible
um so
in reality I not exactly sure of the
answer to would they be eligible to be
reimbursed for the expenses
um based on their disability I think the
answer is probably yes but I I don't
there are other people here that I think
could definitively answer that better
than I
fair enough thank you thank you
representative Schmidt and then Gould
thank you is this going to a
subcommittee uh uh yes okay thank you
representative gold I just wanted to add
on to that so Federal funding that's
already coming to the state for these
Services I'm assuming fiscal committee
and and the and the money managers would
be part of what funded this but it would
give it a department to manage the money
yes this will be coming to fiscal
if if
I'm sorry yes Finance
okay thank you I have uh an additional
question uh I know you said this was
being introduced as a Senate bill and I
noticed that Senate Bill 214 has the
exact same language why should we bother
to do anything with this if the Senate
is going to do it because
with all due respect what a strong
message that the house could send to the
Senate and we'd come together and have a
Reconciliation bill with um I think it
sends a strong message to our state
yes thank you representative leckis
uh thank you I I share
um an earlier concern with the ability
to really tell if this works in three
years and I want to see you know if you
can allay my concerns I've seen studies
that show that
Head Start results in a an improvement
for the first few years but longer term
uh you know the results revert to the
mean and it has no long-term benefit and
I'm concerned that this would do the
same why why should I believe that's not
going to be the case especially with
only a three-year period to evaluate
I will send you your a lot of research
out there
there are things that happen along the
way in a child's life that can disrupt
their progress in school I I don't think
there's anything that we could do
um to avoid that I think life happens
people their parents might be in an
accident and die and that that could
cause serious problems but that said by
providing high quality
Early Childhood we are giving those
three and four-year-olds the highest
potential for success in future years
I'll take a look at what you sent me
thank you okay represent Gerhard
quick question for you thank you madam
chair is it possible for Manchester to
Institute this on their own without
State can you just do this by yourselves
at the local level or is this you need
permission from the state to do so
Manchester does have an integrated
preschool program
but the program that we are discussing
would be a program that would give all
Manchester children for those parents so
choosing access to this program right
now
um it is my understanding and we have a
school board member here who could
probably answer that question better
that I
um the the
this
bill is more toward access for as many
children as possible whereas uh the the
local
um
municipality
probably I don't know if they would be
able to take on that initiative
just based on the cost alone
all right thank you just follow up
follow up my concern is just putting the
power at the hands of the state when
they miss the local elements have the
most control over it and know what's
going right wrong and so forth so that's
that's where I was going with that thank
you
yes other questions uh representative
again uh thank you um kind of a related
question I see that uh departments only
requiring a 10 match
I assume that's from uh the local school
district and it doesn't have to be cash
it can be in kind yes
um that's concerning I mean you know why
why should that be less than the portion
of Education that's coming from the
state versus the school district for all
the other kids
this is a pilot it's an incentive to get
more
school districts engaged if in fact we
were to go forward remember how long it
took us to get full to get kindergarten
in place and then full day kindergarten
we still don't have every school
district in the state that's right now
taking advantage of full day
kindergarten thank you
representative true
thank you madam chair thank you thank
you for taking my question
I believe you said that uh Department of
Education can't do something like this
because they don't have the authority
for three and four-year-olds so in
setting up this department this is a
department setup outside of the
Department of Education
um that has not been determined yet I
think that will be something that will
be worked out
but it will be its own entity and I
again the Deputy Commissioner is here so
perhaps she could answer that better
than I
well as written it creates a department
parallel to the Department of Education
and not subordinate to it
so representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so
um the the thing the thought that's been
rattling around in my brain ever since
we started talking about this is that
uh
three and four-year-old children uh are
obviously the developmental aspect we're
all I think familiar with it there's a
tremendous brain development so they are
learning but they're also and not very
competent in terms of
other skills
toileting you know taking care of
interacting with other kids and so forth
and so on that it it and that's why I
I'm concerned about the fact that this
has come into committee that
does not have any expertise in this I
understand that we're only opining on
the idea of adding an additional
department but
uh is this something
I know you spoke about this a little bit
at the beginning but
how many other states are doing this
kind of thing and what do we know about
them
well
states have some level of earning early
childhood
program in place Statewide
well what is their experience with that
because uh
you know child care it's either going to
the child is either going to get care
from his or her parents if they are able
to have Mom at home or dad at home or
whatever but
um
many many very young children are with a
caregiver not necessarily an educator so
I realize there's a real Gap in terms of
what the cross-section of children are
getting but I'll be happy in the whole
committee I have um just from the
international committee that I've been
working on I have a number of different
articles and information that relates to
the research and data that I can send to
all of you I didn't want to inundate you
with too much information up front so
I'd be happy to and I think the um
others that are here today might be able
to even point to other information as
well
thank you very much and uh this will be
going to representative broader
subcommittee on state or organization
thank you
yes representative blackis thank you
um I mean the previous question raised
uh uh
an interesting point that we're you know
education really isn't in our our
wheelhouse is this going to go before
the education committee
we don't it's an early Bill we don't
know where it's going okay okay thank
you thank you I mean that's that's the
case we never know what word committee
is going to and thank you for hearing my
testimony I hope you
can thank you representative Heath
Sean Parr
thank you madam chair and the rest of
the committee my name is Sean Parr I'm
on the Manchester School Board uh where
I sit on the policy committee and chair
the education legislation committee
today I'm speaking on behalf of the
Manchester School Board which has
authorized me to advocate for funding
for Universal Pre-K Pre-K programming
and related facilities costs we are
therefore unanimous in our support of
the Pre-K pilot program and the
establishment of a department of early
childhood education as proposed in hb620
Pre-K education mitigates the effects of
poverty and adversity on our children
especially benefiting our English
language Learners as well as our poor
and disadvantaged children our current
lack of affordable Early Learning
options short changes our children and
research shows clearly that high quality
Early Education can improve High School
graduation rates and future employment
income it leads to long-term educational
attainment gains through improvements in
behavior and it allows children to grow
up to raise stronger families and
contribute to society we need to give
our children the kind of care and early
learning they need to fulfill their
their potential kids who attend public
preschool programs are better prepared
for kindergarten than kids who don't we
ask for your support of this bill thanks
for your consideration
thank you are there any questions from
the committee representative Schmidt
thank you so it's interesting that
you're coming in strong support
that that clearly has value in our
decision making but the question I have
is is there the instrumentality out
there in terms of
people who are trained to take care of
and educate because this is not just
taking care of kids right this is
supposed to be educating them uh is
there is there the staff and support
experience available in this state to do
that
I believe so I mean we already we as uh
representative Heath mentioned we do
have some Pre-K programs for special
needs children already and we do have
staff that teach and and run those
programs there our administrative
infrastructure would allow for including
additional staff members for this pilot
for sure yes
could you opine on what the rest of the
state because of Manchester is a kind of
a world unto itself what the rest of the
state might be capable of doing I mean I
think that's a difficult question I
think that there are Workforce shortages
in so many different fields across so
many different areas of the state and
the country right now that it would be a
little bit presumptuous of me to to
speculate on that uh I think
uh we've had success with incentivizing
staff uh applications for staff with uh
with uh hiring bonuses and retention
bonuses in the past year and that's been
successful in fully Staffing our our
district right now
um and maybe just to address one of your
earlier points there about Manchester it
is unique right it is the largest
District in the State uh with 12 300
students in our district but it's also
the most diverse City in this in the
state right and so almost half of our
students are non-white students many
coming from our City's Refugee
population so there are many learning
challenges that happen when those
children enter our schools right and so
that kind of immediate immersion
requires a lot of support so we are
definitely used to adding supports for
our students there and that's why this
kind of a bill can make a huge
difference for our students there by
introducing them to the structure of
school the acclimation to the English
language and that kind of regular
exposure to socializing with other
children learning the alphabet sooner
early literacy all of those things so
this would be a real game changer for
students in our city and I think across
the state
yeah follow-up thank you so the thing is
uh if you're already kind of doing this
then you're already definitely spending
money on it and and uh so that means
more more money out of taxpayers pockets
right that's where it's coming so the
funding for pre pre-K in Manchester is
solely from federal funding it's not
from local taxation so right now we are
only using federal funds that's why the
program is limited the access is very
limited to certain students who have
certain needs or qualify under certain
uh poverty limits so it's a very limited
program right now you can the access is
extremely limited so that's why as
representative Heath mentioned there the
access is the key word there that
increasing access to pre-k is extremely
important so so you're looking I know
it's going to supplement the uh correct
federal funds thank you any other
questions from Mr Parr representative
Simon thank you madam chair how long
have you guys been running your uh
preschool program it's it's predates my
time on the board so I would say it's
been several years several years being a
New Hampshire school do you have any
data that you'd be able to share with us
to show how that program is impacting
long-term educational outcomes and
graduation rates I can look up that data
and I can I can find I can ask the
superintendent to see if we can share
that with the committee that'd be very
helpful thank you
another question
representative Gerhard thank you madam
chair a lot of what you described
socialization learning all that stuff
don't don't um I don't want to say just
religious but social groups and
organizations do that within the city as
well or is there just a void where
that's not filled at all
I mean I would say the answer is yes to
both I mean there are yes organizations
do some of that work right but
parents are often
in need of wanting more of those options
and more of those choices for their
children right and and it is very
expensive to put your children into
Pre-K programs for three-year-olds
four-year-olds and earlier
um
the kind of regular those organizations
are also usually one or two days a week
this is which this would be more days
per week than that more hours per day in
those situations a much more sustained
routinized uh longer lasting impact
all right thank you thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much
D Lee champagne
hi everyone my name is Deli champagne
and I work for Save the Children Action
Network and before I talk to you today I
just want to thank you I know how hard
of a job you're doing I know you get a
hundred dollars a year I I am just so
impressed with people like you
who put the time and effort into being
here and you're going to be driving home
in a snowstorm so your efforts don't go
unnoticed by people in this state so
thank you
so
um I'm not going to read my testimony
but I'm just going to read the first
paragraph
um scan is the acronym for Save the
Children Action Network and we're the
political arm of save the children and
we work to build bipartisan support to
make sure every child has a strong start
in life we've been saved the children
it's been around for over 100 years but
scan has been in New Hampshire since
2014.
so I want to tell you what I did
in 2020 I saw a movie called starting at
zero
whoa this movie was incredible it was by
a documentary filmmaker a woman who by
the way did her internship at nhpr
she now lives in Rhode Island
and she highlighted the states that have
gotten this done
and primarily she highlighted Alabama
so I called her and I said can we get
together I want to know more about the
work that you've researched your film is
incredible
so she said well let's do one better
I'll come to New Hampshire so she's
supported by a foundation and then she
came to New Hampshire and she brought
with her the commissioner of the newly
formed Department of early childhood
education in Alabama her name is Gina
Ross Commissioner Ross they came to New
Hampshire in September we showed the
film at Red River Theaters we had about
a hundred people there and then we had a
panel discussion after and we said how
do we get this done in New Hampshire so
many other states are getting it done
help us get this done so since then
Alabama has offered us free technical
assistance this Foundation pays for it
and Gina Ross I called her yesterday I
said I need to know the return on
investment I want to put that in my
testimony she said okay I'll send it to
you right now she's been in an
incredible help to us and has offered to
stay on board to help us they are one
one of the poorest states in the country
and she has figured out how to blend and
braid
finances to get it done in that state
she said you guys are like the seventh
richest state in the country if we can
get it done you can get it done
so they have done a lot of research
about the return on investment about the
dollar return about the kids that
actually graduate from high school that
weren't graduating from high school so I
do have some of that for you but what
the foundation did was they knew you
were going to want this information so
they put together something that I'm
going to send you it's the film
and then it's the panel discussion
afterwards so you can see how it
happened in Alabama so they
um sent me an email and said forward
this on to your lawmakers and they have
offered to come to New Hampshire to
speak with any of you we tried to get a
meeting together with Governor sununu I
reached out
um with I was working with Senator
Carson and Senator Whitley and we went
right up to the governor's office and
said can we meet with the governor and
they said yeah he would love to hear
about this but we have not been able to
get on his schedule and Gina Ross has
said on a dime I will jump on a plane
and come and meet with your governor
I talked to her yesterday and she said
any luck with getting a meeting with the
governor and I said not yet and she said
Deli I have
um friends in the governor's office in
Alabama that know him let me see if I
can connect it that way
so I just want you to know we have been
working on this we had a committee that
worked on this all summer long we have
another bill a Senate bill that's going
to address the workforce shortage so
that we can have
qualified teachers in these programs
it's a different curriculum why which is
why she highly recommended it not be
part of the doe because children zero
through five it's a play-based
curriculum you've probably heard of
Reggio Emilia or creative curriculum
those are all based on play and
kindergarten through 12th is an academic
curriculum so that's why we'd like to
see it separate and not part of the doe
and she said it is so vitally important
to the economy of your state and the
welfare of Children and Families that it
deserves its own department so she's she
said to me you fight for that department
that's what we did in Alabama and it is
working for us
so we I've also researched other states
on average for every dollar invested in
early childhood Ed there's a range but
the the lowest return is four dollars
and the highest return for some States
has been 16
so there's an economist I wrote about
him and I'll send you that that has done
a lot of work around this and he's done
the research and I looked at his numbers
and his statistics and then I also went
and looked at other states that are
getting it done
um Oklahoma five dollars and 12 cents
for every dollar spent Tennessee I think
was a little over four dollars Georgia
they're they're all seeing a return on
their investment and kids are thriving
we know that many kids have Aces if we
don't want a child to go through life
with traumatic experiences we have to
provide positive experiences that's what
preschool does it provides positive of
experiences to mitigate Aces so this is
to me it's a no-brainer and I'm so
frustrated that it hasn't happened
sooner I actually taught preschool a
number of years ago and it's probably
one of the most rewarding and important
jobs I've ever done I'm I'm a nationally
award-winning
teacher at the middle school level but
it was where I made the most impact I
thought was in the preschool classroom
so I will I will send you I I got you
something from Alabama from the research
that they had done I will send you that
and I will give you my testimony and I'm
happy to take questions
thank you very much representative Simon
and then Schmidt
thank you you
um you referenced return on the dollar
how was that measured
so many states do it different ways but
um for example I'll tell you the um
Alabama return on investment was through
retention so their numbers increased of
kids not having to be held back and I
have the figure right here
a 126 million dollars has been saved
um without having to retain children
because they started out in preschool
and not just kindergarten so that's one
measure but there are different
different states different states have
done different measures
so so you may when you say one state
sixteen dollars one you'd have to look
at each individual report it's not an
Apples to Apples comparison correct yep
thank you so much you're welcome
representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair uh I think I know
what Aces means uh but maybe since this
is not a children and you're right not
everybody might know what I mean so but
that's not my question but I'll explain
it after okay so could it be that uh
that because young children are so
different in as I was kind of alluding
to earlier in my other question
uh so different from uh older children
who are already more skilled in all
virtually everything that it really is
kind of a separate world
a lot of
emotional emotional social emotional
growth and development and that happens
through play and kids don't even realize
that they're learning when they play
um you know you can learn science in
social studies when you play so it's
it's it's a different curriculum it's
not sitting down at a desk listening to
a teacher teach so they're different
it's hard to say that you could put this
department under the doe and maybe
that's what has to happen we have some
statute that maybe we have to look at
but there's a strong argument for them
to be separate because the curriculum is
so different
Aces okay adverse childhood experiences
so do we have time for this because I'd
love to okay so let me just tell you
there was a study done years ago on why
people who were losing weight
um were gaining it back so the doctor
met with a number of obese people and
said tell me about your childhoods and
this is disturbing but one of the
questions he asked was when was your
first sexual experience
and they were answering three four six
seven
and he said oh my God this is this is
awful so he developed this study and
it's called the aces study and there are
10 there are more than 10 but 10 on
average adverse childhood experiences
that we measure in children and we say
if a child has four or more of those
then they're considered traumatized so a
positive childhood experience can
mitigate that or lessen that there are
there are all kinds of articles online
about the aces study it's fascinating
check it out I would highly recommend
that you learn more about Aces it's the
like the public health problem they're
saying of the century you know that
we're not addressing trauma in children
thank you other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
Teresa Rosenberg
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee I'm Teresa Rosenberger I
work for the law firm of Bernstein Shore
and I'm here today
I'm an informational point of view only
representing Waterford upstart Waterford
upstart is a
um
pre-kindergarten Readiness program that
started in 2009 in Utah
and the it was started as a pilot
program
it is now in over 30 state it has been
in New Hampshire since 2020 they started
as a pilot program down in Nashua and
working with the city of Nashua and
United Way what it is
I feel like I'm talking too loud
what it is it's a program where a
three-year-old four-year-old
pre-kindergarten child signs up with the
parents they receive a computer
they receive internet connection if they
don't have it and they are given a
software program where it's 15 to 20
minutes a day five days a week that the
child has owned this program they're
also given a coach uh the coaches is
when I say not present it's not
necessarily somebody down the street
they're giving a coach the program
assesses the child before the program
and the program assesses the child
afterwards uh there is a summer program
and there's also a school year school
year program the one that started
initially in Nashua had almost 100 kids
and it was basically the summer program
and the outcomes were tremendous and
they really they really these kids
really did a great job
learning and they can what's interesting
about it to me is that the coach can
watch the program how the child's using
it during the entire process so the
coach Can See For example oh gosh this
child's using this program 45 minutes a
day or an hour a day or the child's
using in a weekend which they're not
supposed to be doing it's supposed to be
15 minutes and five days a week and so
then the coach is going to call up and
say just curious what's going on what's
been really interesting in a couple of
cases what they found is the parent
using the program because a parent stops
school at eighth grade and the parent
has found that the program actually is
really terrific it's Math Science and
reading concentrating mainly on reading
for um
new Americans or Americans who who
English isn't the first language it's
been tremendous for the kids but also
the parents the parents as well there
are supplements to the program that you
can bring in for other kids if they
really want to work on math and science
so that started in 2020 and I will say
the outcomes in Nashville were
tremendous 93 percent of the children
who took the program were had
kindergarten Readiness at the advanced
level which is tremendous and so it's
work it's working across the country
it's working here in 2022
um the the state applied for arpa funds
and the program received are per fund
um to take the program Statewide it is
now in its first year of the entire year
we now have almost 5 500 kids in the
program a little less than that
it'll go through the end of the school
year it'll be really interesting to see
what the results are then and then
hopefully we'll do summer summer again
um I wanted to let you also know that in
doing this we've done it totally in
cooperation with doe they have been a
fabulous partner they have helped us
recruit the biggest issue we have is
recruiting Because you need to get to
those families and have children who are
three or four and getting ready to go go
to to school so doe has been tremendous
in helping us with recruiting
introducing us all the resources we need
to be out there working we actually have
a lady in New Hampshire that's on the
ground recruiting these kits
um do even doe even this summer brought
in HHS and we had a great meeting with
HHS because if you think about it when
they're looking at housing for lower
income or they're looking at at Early
Childhood issues medical issues ETC they
know where the families are they're in
touch and so they've been they've been
tremendous it's been great working with
them I will say
um doe I I am impressed I say this maybe
I shouldn't say it but I am impressed
they aren't working in a silo and I
think that's unfortunately what we see
too often in government You've Got The
Silo here here and here but they are
really they really are trying to work in
the bigger perspective and um and have
recruitment uh as far as
um
I mean I've talked to you about the
outcomes I think to me that's
interesting right now you're seeing a
number of Ukrainian children sign up for
the program
I'm here to answer any questions it's
been successful we're hoping New
Hampshire can continue
um our grant over this summer but we may
be able to extend it uh and so far we
also have asked for responses from the
parents or responses from the parents
have been tremendous
are there any questions
represent villain
thank you madam chair
um my question is
it's great we're doing with preschool
but it's my contention and observation
that part of the issue is parenting yes
we don't teach parents how to parent
as opposed to teaching
preschoolers how to be a preschooler and
and how to play and so forth is there
any part of this program that extends to
parents to say this is how you be a good
parent this is how you encourage your
kids to do what they should be doing yes
and thank you representative Dolan you
helped me out because I can tell you I
can't always read too well what I've
scribbled and the part I forgot is the
parenting part the program works
tremendously with the parents and the
whole point is at doing it at home and
not doing it at a Learning Center or
doing in a school is it has to have
involvement with a parent and the parent
has to help with turning on the computer
the parent has to help with getting the
program there so the entire focus on
this is trying to get parental
involvement when these children are
three and four and as they've done this
over the country it looks like that
really is paying paying off we're new
here in New Hampshire but in other
places but that's one of the tenants of
it is getting parental involvement and
thank you so much because I forgot that
part
thank you we heard earlier that the plan
for the pre-k program was play-based
education but it from what you're
describing it sounds a lot more
academic which seems I question whether
that's appropriate in that age group but
well you know I have three children and
I was probably not a really nice parent
and that they were only allowed when
they were young 30 minutes of TV a day
and it couldn't be each one they had to
agree on the program so you can imagine
what it was it was PBS and way back when
my children are now in their 30s and 40s
when going to school the PBS programming
there was the science program there was
the one two three I forgot what it was
all called but the PBS program it was
really geared at those kids but geared
is to learning through
um
I'm not going to say learning through
play because you can't play on TV but it
was fun it wasn't like that this that's
exactly what this program's like and I'd
be more than happy if you like to come
in at some point and um bring your
computer and let you all see the the 15
minutes
I hate to say it's PBS based it's not
but it's it's more what's inspired more
it's more fun learning for kids so
you're going to have you're going to
have a cat bouncing around like this and
figuring out how to count thank you yeah
okay you're welcome other questions
representative Gould
you said you weren't speaking in support
of our or against the bill my question
to you is would the program you're
working on be harmed in any way if a
department of early childhood education
was established I don't think so because
when I looked at this this is
multifaceted and multi-based and it's
everything from in the home so no I
don't think so hopefully we can
integrate in it and the only reason
we're not taking a position we're
totally in support of
kindergarten Readiness but as to where
you put it I mean from my perspective
frankly I like it in places that aren't
going to Silo and so I think doe has
been doing a great job and with the
collaboration with DHHS but we really
are here advocating for Readiness
programs for children but I think such
as multi it's with multi we would we'd
be fine I think okay
other questions
seeing none thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 620.
yes
good afternoon everyone I'm Christine
Brennan Deputy Commissioner from the
Department of Education I also serve as
co-counsel with Trish Tilly from the
Department of Health and Human Services
on our Council for thriving children I'm
a long time educator for over 40 decades
and served under Mary Heath who was an
absolutely passionate person about
education it's wonderful to be
collaborating with her again I guess
what I want to talk about with this bill
is really give you a little bit of
context in education around what we've
been doing to try to really break down
the silos with the Department of Health
and Human Services really look at what
are some of the duplicative services
that we have that that agency is doing
and that what we're doing around
professional development and really
looking at some of the gaps because the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I've been studying this for a long
time so there is lots of confusion they
have the children I almost think of as
infant
um they have an infant until they are
five years old and so then they
transition them to our agency the
Department of Education and so that
transition time is really something that
needs lots of lots of improvement and
that's really with this preschool
development Grant we've been looking at
what would be the best way to organize
early childhood education and there were
four options that we've been studying
and so I'm going to kind of look at this
bill in two ways first where the office
should sit there is under the governor's
office there there's right now the way
we're doing it operating it separately
and having memorandums of understanding
there's it could be under Department of
Health and Human Services or it could be
under Department of Education there are
um two there there's lots of pots of
money that help us you know serve our
Littles around the state two of them
being one um there's two big ones it's
our ccdf fund that's at the Department
of Health and Human Services and then we
have our idea Part B that serves
preschool special education students
those are the two largest pots of
funding and our Ida funding cannot be
anywhere else except for under the
Department of Health and humans I mean
under us we can't move that around it
has to stay under us I will this came
hot off the press this really is a great
document and it's called integrated
efficient early care and education
system
and it lays out how all of the other
states have been organizing themselves
around early childhood and right now 25
states have it under the Department of
Education and so I'll be sure to send
you this document
um
so that is about the office of early
childhood and then when we look at the
pilot which is ABS like right now we are
we learn through covid that looking at
how we serve our youngest children is
absolutely essential how we build their
Foundation I think the time is right to
think about how we could do it
differently we are already through our
preschool development Grant looking at a
pilot and this pilot is starting now
we're getting a task force together and
we're hoping it's not going to be a
three-year study right now we have we'll
be doing it for a year and this is under
the Department of Health and Human
Services funding under the ccdf and our
hope is that we are going to gain input
from leaders we are going to be having a
final report we'll be defining some of
the policies looking at some of the
potential costs
um considerations and this should be
over and finished in by September 30th
and I have to say that I am so impressed
with all of these kind of questions that
you've been asking because I can tell
that you are
um understanding the importance of our
early years and the Brain development
that happens the servant return and how
crucial it is to making sure that
children are not only successful in the
younger years but it continues on
thank you are there any guests
representative Gould thank you madam
chair thank you for coming in and
testifying my question is you talked
about this already work workers and
funding in two different departments
Health and Human Services and Department
of Education are there also workers that
would mitigate to this or migrate to
this new department so in terms of
adding more employees I've looked in the
bill we'd have a commissioner and then
we'd have them they could set up
departments do you see people already
doing these tasks that could move into I
think that that we part of once the
office has decided where it will sit we
will have to look at what the what
functions
this office will serve and where they'll
be sitting so I do imagine that there
would be a lot of Shifting around of
positions and I think that it's not my
office so I don't want to speak for the
Department of Health and Human Services
but their funding is tied to you know
lots of Eligibility issues
other questions working on assignment
thank you madam chair
um as I'm listening to testimony today
I'm trying to
kind of reconcile a couple of pieces of
data that seem to Conflict for me and
being from the Department hopefully you
can help me out with that a little bit
but I've heard that all but Six States
have implemented implemented this kind
of program
but I also constantly hear that New
Hampshire has the third highest
education system public education system
in the country
um and so if the argument is that we
need to implement this to have better
outcomes how how is how do we reconcile
those two things and also the two states
that are supposedly better than us do
they have these programs or do they not
have these programs so I think there's I
think some of the discrepancies that you
hear is is depends on what criterias
that we're using to measure and so
that's where some of the confusion
happens because I think we are when we
look at the state how we how we educate
our kids we do pretty well and I think
we fail on some of the research because
we don't have state funded pre-k and one
of the things about this mixed delivery
system that I think is important for all
of us to know is it's a mixed delivery
system that we're looking to study
saying it's very very broad is what what
is it that families want that are going
to have access that fits their
individual child and Family's needs and
that's what we're looking to study so it
could be a home-based um
program it could be a child license
program it could be an in-school and so
part of this task force is to look at
which which
um
you know which Best Suits the family
needs and then what's the best child
outcomes and our IDE Part B
has a program that looks at child
outcomes for special needs students
already set up
where Department of Health and Human
Services they have a qris system that I
don't think it measures any of the
schooling or preschool or academics
portion of preschool
all right
thank you madam chair
um thank you for that answer I
appreciate it um my other question is
when we're looking at other programs
that have been implemented around the
country have any of those states that
you're aware of started having
conversations about making this
compulsory one concern that I have is
that if you have a state-run program
state-run education programs tend to
become compulsory over time and then we
would be talking about having you know
two Euros in a compulsory program away
from their families so I don't think
that they use a little compulsory but
it's called Universal preschool I mean
there's always there's there's always
um
and I think it depends on there are
states that I think have it I'd have to
research I want to get some let me it's
it's
um it's more the judicial term when you
look at Supreme Court law around these
kinds of cases typically when they find
it um they describe it as being
compulsory in other words the parent
doesn't have a choice okay the state is
requiring that they Implement uh put
their child into one of these programs
so yeah I don't think that that's what
we're looking to do here with this mixed
delivery service I think that we know
that New Hampshire is unique and
different and that the state has
different parts that that need different
kinds of services I think um we know
what we're learning with our education
system too is that kids are unique and
different and need different Pathways to
be successful in school and I think that
that's what we're hoping to have here
with our preschool kiddos thank you so
much
other questions representative Schmidt
so what are the five or six other states
that we've heard do not yet have
one of these programs I will have to get
back to you on who they are
um I I don't have that information do
you know that Mary
I know the New Hampshire but we I know
it's New Hampshire is one of them I
thought we were all the other five were
curious about it any
what's that any other questions I have a
question you say you're already starting
a pilot program how is that different
from the pilot program specified in this
bill I think what what's different a
little bit is that theirs is a lot much
longer ours is only a year study
um and there's is much longer and I
think that the 10 match is different
that that what we're looking for because
I think it would be hard for let's say
we were looking at um
uh church-based programs for them to get
the 10 it would be a little bit
different and they have some of the
national ner
um standards that are in there that may
make it a little bit costly
could I not being familiar with all
those things could I interpret your
response to be not much different except
for the extended spam yes okay thank you
that's
want to make sure that was my
understanding was correct anyone else
then chip and I just mentioned that it's
our intent too it's okay please come up
and and speak on this one
this is great
we've known each other since she was a
little baby practically
um it's our intent to build off the
learning that takes place in that pilot
that um commissioner Brennan a Deputy
Commissioner Brandon just talked about
thank you that makes it a little clearer
it's okay representative Simon thank you
again Madam chair sorry that just
sparked another question for me that
it's kind of related to the one that I
had before if we go ahead with this
pilot program and we start studying what
it would mean for the State of New
Hampshire and then we decide hey this is
a great idea so we want to implement it
I'm assuming that's going to require
taxpayer funds in order to implement but
I would assume at the same time you have
no intention of making compulsory which
means some students will be in it and
some students won't be in it but I
assume we would still be charging all
taxpayers for the program
um
has has the department or anybody given
any thought to revenue streams for this
is it just going to be through
um taxpayer funding if we end up going
in this direction so my understanding
and again I'm not the Department of
Health and Human Services but this is
under the C that this pilot is under the
ccdf funding which is federal funding
um just do this study and that's
allowable under under that fund
follow-up follow-up yes but the federal
funding will cover the expense of the
study itself but we're doing the study I
would assume to get to a result right to
get to a final report to get to a report
and that report would then be to
recommend either mixing the program
because it doesn't it's not effective or
expanding the program and if we expand
the program once again if it's not
compulsory it's not covering all
students but so what is the what is the
potential have we given thought to
revenue stream yeah so thank you for
this question because I think it will
help clarify I don't think that any of
those perimeters are established and
that's what this task force is is going
to be doing
um looking at trying to look at what we
will be studying what what is the long
term
um like what what
kind of groups are we going to be
studying and what's going to be the long
term and what are some of the costs and
what are some of the policies that may
need to change so and none of those are
established yet but we're hoping to do
that within one year and this is through
this funding is also through preschool
development grants so we're trying to
get some facilitators
um that will help us move us along that
are well versed in the topic yeah thank
you
other questions come representative
Gerhart just one quick one madam
it's you said you're talking to parents
to find out what they need or want for
preschool needs wouldn't it be easier
just to provide the money to parents for
said services and they could choose the
ones they want and then we could avoid
creating a whole new department and all
the bureaucracy associated with it that
could be an option
sounds good to me representative Lucas
thank you um so if I correct my my
understanding if it's if it's wrong but
it sounds like
we're supposed to we're being asked to
gear up an entire department for a pilot
study which seems a little strange to me
particularly since there's already a
pilot yes in progress it makes seems to
make no sense how does this make sense
me what someone
um I think it makes sense that we are
looking at and elevating the need for an
office of Early Childhood so that we can
think about how we use the funds the
federal funds
um
and Serve the People
all right thank you okay another
questions
all right
um we're all looking glazed so I think
it's time uh thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
all right seeing them I'll close the
hearing this is going to subcommittee
and uh we'll see what happens
uh yes of course
but if you want to recommend killing it
over Senate bill can go forward
is
I think I'm going to drive home myself
okay
what are they thinking do they have no
respect for our time and effort
thank you so much for your response on
the cemetery and obviously
now oh yeah
scary world was her name she's retired
students from New Hampshire originally I
went to Chicago and now California can I
give you your email address
yeah
it's the name of that Cemetery sounds
Vaguely Familiar but it's not one of the
big ones in Epson and she'll she'll be
able she started The Descendants she's
like big into the lineage societies so
she started the descendants of New
Hampshire
okay she'll she'll have that before
but at least if you started in the right
Cemetery it's a lot easier yes
there's a recycling bin unless you think
there's going to be great demand
we are on for tomorrow
you're not talking right into it you're
not getting much of it
foreign